tournoi des candidats en passant par le
speechestre ou les titles Tuesday
chaise.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition aux pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chaise.com stash
events aussi bien sur le site internet
ou sur nos applications iOS et Android
pour vivre votre passion comme nulle
part ailleurs
[Musique]
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'émoticônes et même
vos personnalités préférées du monde des
échecs émoticônes et les emojis
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts spéciales restent sur les chéquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
vous voulez streamer des échecs comme
vos créateurs préférés tels que Blist
stream Naka ou les
soeurs.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors d'autres
plateformes de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/settings
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamer en direct votre
profites.com affichera votre stream
twitch qui sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties offert utiliser la
commande community streamer dans le chat
et faites grossir votre audience sans
plus attendre
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
finale du
speechez pardon avec Nakamura contre
Magnus Carlson oui les joueurs à l'écran
à l'instant le masque qui va commencer
ici deux minutes normalement donc
rapidement si vous offre un petit tour
sur le bracket voir un peu ce qui s'est
passé dans cet événement donc on a ici
Nakamura qui a été intratable
intraitable dans ce tournoi en battant
hyundangui 19,9 en super battu car wanna
18 et demi 8 et demi et ensuite en
demi-finale il a éliminé mvl mvl qui a
fait un très très gros match en
s'imposant dans les cadences de Blitz
qui c'est malheureusement incliné en
Bullet
et Magnus de son côté il a battu visiter
17,5 pour ensuite battre nepo 20,5
donc c'est vraiment des scores qui sont
qui sont un peu écrasant dans ce match
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez et
vous dans cette finale est-ce que vous
avez des favoris entre Magnus et
henaca pour moi c'est c'est hyper hyper
chaud c'est hyper close comme match je
pense franchement que le joueur qui va
être le plus en forme va remporter
l'événement donc le score entre les deux
joueurs en speechs c'est 2-1 en faveur
de manus malus qui a perdu le dernier
match qu'il a joué l'année dernière
contre Naka ça c'est joué à un point je
crois que le score c'était un truc du
style 14,5 il me semble si j'ai pas de
bêtises et donc très très gros score en
tout cas le masque qui va commencer j'ai
eu 4 scène qui avait annoncé que le
match allait être très très compliqué
qui est très important pour lui donc
voilà un petit peu ce qui va se passer
donc Kevin n'est pas n'est pas sur la
chaîne aujourd'hui malheureusement
il m'a donné la place mais je crois
qu'il stream j'ai entendu dire qu'il a
le streamer depuis Paris vous savez
qu'il y a la la backup qui commence ce
week-end et je crois qu'il va le
commenter là-bas après je sais pas si
compte
twitch est aussi je connaissais pas mais
aujourd'hui du coup c'est moi qui suis
sur cheescom.fr les joueurs qui sont
prêts on a Naka qui va commencer
avec avec les blancs dans cette première
partie ça commence avec le 4
je vais mettre mon son un peu plus fort
parce que j'ai du mal à entendre
les coups voilà donc tout est bon c'est
une espagnole dans cette première partie
et vous voyez ici en fait rapidement
pour les cadences qui sont affichés
juste en dessous de moi on va avoir 1h30
de 5 + 1 ensuite on aura une heure deux
trois plus un et pour finir une
demi-heure de bullette en une plus une
donc c'est un match très très compliqué
où tous les points comptent
donc je pense qu'en 3 + 1 et 5 + 1 j'ai
envie de donner quand même une
on va dire Magnus favoris qu'avant cela
le cadence on peut plus jouer aux échecs
comme la Russie quand même un meilleur
joueur un meilleur joueur d'échec
normalement donc dans les cadences avec
plus de temps je pense que je pense que
Magnus doit être légèrement devant
en plus est-ce que c'est Ivan c'est pas
clair en fait les deux joueurs en Bullet
sont monstrueux et pour le coup en fait
dans le circuit
Naka c'est vraiment le meilleur joueur
de Bullet mais Magnus j'ai l'impression
qu'il a pas non plus de de faiblesse
c'est à dire que par rapport à Naka par
exemple il y a aucun aucune cadence dans
lequel il va vraiment être derrière
donc c'est un match qui qui est hyper
chaud c'est le gros derby
des matchs sur Internet c'est le match
quoi on est tous bon on aurait préféré
on aurait préféré mvl Carcen mais bon on
va se contenter quand même de quinzaine
Naka c'est aussi un super super match
donc C5 a été joué
cavalier 2 donc le plan basique c'est
cavaliers F1 qui avait 3 et jouer à un
moment donné des 4 c'est assez standard
dans ces positions
donc là il y a plein de coups je pense
que tout revu doit être un coup
peut-être fou mais ça tu en a un aussi
à trois on peut jouer à trois dans plein
de variantes en fait vous savez que ces
positions de de donc là c'est une
espagnole mais on peut avoir cette
position dans une Sicilienne ça
transpose un peu dans une ligne
plein de coups sont possibles à quatre
souvent impossible aussi
à 3 B4 il y a plein de plein de
possibilités
Marshall je suis pas sûr que j'aurais
envie vraiment de de balancer un
Marshall en plus le Marshall maintenant
il y a quand même beaucoup de variantes
qui font nul direct donc bon je pense
quand elle est blanc dans un match comme
ça
tu as envie quand même de de
jouer avec tes blancs quoi tu as envie
de profiter de de
l'avantage des blancs alors maudit sur
Youtube que le son est horrible est-ce
que le son est horrible dites-moi un
petit peu si
le son est vraiment et vraiment horrible
ou si c'est un truc
ou si ça vient de notre ami sur YouTube
a priori cela doit être normal
tu dis que ça résonne alors peut-être
que
est-ce que c'est mieux comme ça il y a
un miniaco ok là je ne changera un truc
parce que ça va mieux je pense que j'ai
ça devrait aller en fait je pense que
j'ai pas changé le set up depuis depuis
la dernière fois donc on va avoir les
mêmes conditions normalement faut B3
ok je peux aussi rapprocher le micro il
est devant moi quand même ça change pas
grand chose hop
c'est
ok alors faut B3 donc là on peut avoir
dans B3 ou apprend B3 donc souvent on
aime bien faire après pour ouvrir la God
a et avoir enfin essayer de provoquer
ici un petit pion arriéré en raciste
après tu apprends aussi est possible
donc nakaki qui prend son temps
avant de commencer ouais c'est la partie
numéro 1 le score c'est 0 0
donc après a été joué
le micro proche ok ça marche je touche
plus rien là
je touche plus à rien des cinq qui
étaient toujours réaction normale donc
soit on faire plus on prend pour
attaquer le petit pion en E5 sur
piondre le pion de 5 après tour des 8
plus on est trois qui pourraient être
faible donc là je sais pas si on va
manger
en dessin
je vous ai laissé la joie est-ce que
vous voulez que j'enlève la jauge
j'ai vu que Kévin l'avait enlevé sauf
pour le Bullet moi je sais pas je m'en
fous un peu est-ce que vous préférez
avoir la jauge je préfère que je
l'enlève
oui ça veut dire quoi ce que vous aimez
ou est-ce que vous voulez faire
oui c'est oui c'est bien
OK
faut faire un sondage ouais
c'était quoi déjà le truc c'est Paul non
je crois
je vais faire un sondage
[Musique]
alors on va faire simple jauge oui non
allez je vous laisse deux minutes
dites moi si la soupe
moi ça m'est complètement égal mais
c'est vrai que des fois sur le chat vous
préférez vous préférez
alors voilà je vous aviez pas je crois
que pour l'instant on a quand même un
gros
beaucoup de
encore le temps de voter
ok donc on croise ça a été joué donc il
y avait une menace éventuellement de
fous prends h65 jours avec un problème
sur le cavalier
une prédiction on va faire des
prédictions les gars sur sur les 7 sur
tout ça salut malin
alors wash j'ai 4 c'est un coup c'est de
ramener un peu le les pièces sur le roi
en tout cas qui se met un peu mal au
temps Naka qui généralement quand même
joue très très vite et aimer la pression
en tout cas dans cette partie c'est pas
le cas il est un petit peu en arrière
Manu ce qui joue vite qui a l'air serein
la même l'aire de bien se faire chier là
j'ai vu la pause qu'il avait et le
second mais
non les joueurs sont très sérieux les
joueurs veulent gagner ce match pourquoi
c'est important Naka il a toute sa
communauté qui le suit derrière pour lui
c'est un match important et Magnus il
l'a dit il l'a dit il a dit que que
ce match est important il veut garder le
lead donc donc les deux joueurs veulent
absolument gagner ce match
parce que en plus des en plus des enjeux
financiers bon ces joueurs sont n'ont
pas besoin c'est pas vraiment pour
l'argent qu'ils font c'est pour moi là
c'est surtout pour pour
le prestige pour faire le tournoi pour
voilà ils aiment bien c'est le tournoi
je pense que le format est assez cool
quand même et c'est pour ça aussi qu'il
joue cet endroit là
sont quand même fan d'échec ils adorent
ça donc c'est vraiment cool et on a un
84% enfin 80% pardon avec plein de 84
watts pour oui donc on va garder la
jauge du coup
on va faire si vous voulez un petit je
sais pas si j'ai des modos dans le chat
des modaux qui pourraient éventuellement
m'aider faire des prédictions à ce que
penser de ce 7
voilà c'est moi la prédit
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce cette
qui va gagner le 7
qui va gagner le 5 + 1
voilà je vous laisse faire
ou je mets nul
ce que je mets nul ou est-ce que je
j'annule sinon je mets
vous avez 5 minutes pour voter
pour voter ce que vous
ce que vous voulez
alors qui va gagner ce stade à votre
avis Magnus Naka nul
une minute 32 pour Magnus contre 20
secondes pour Naka dans cette position
et Magnus qui sont apparaît du pion le 4
il y a un pion de plus pour les Noirs
mais une structure un petit peu
affaiblie mais je pense qu'elle a un bel
avantage noir qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
jouer aussi est-ce que j'ai 6 c'est un
coup
en l'air je viens de dire une grosse
bêtise
OK
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer ici c'est pas
facile
de la part de Magnus alors c'est prise
il veut manger comme ça les deux
cavaliers sont en prises c'est bien ça
l'idée mais bon ça me faisait un peu
peur avec le avec le vis-à-vis alors j'y
pensais à gagner 4 mais juste en coup de
Bullet quoi j'ai pas vraiment
j'y croyais pas quoi quand je quand je
l'ai vu c'était plus le fait de le voir
c'est une chose mais le fait de le jouer
c'est un autre donc prise comment est-ce
qu'on continue la partie ici parce que
ça peut être un coup taquet le pion F2
ici
et salut à tous sur le chat ce qui
arrive vous pouvez voter vous avez je
vous ai mis une petite prédit sur le 7
de 5 + 1 vous avez Magnus Naka ou nul en
tout cas il y a des gros lignes sur
Magnus je vous conseille de parler
peut-être Naka pour la côte franchement
à 10000 contre dans un 45000 il a quand
même une belle côte maca hein pour pour
remporter ce set alors que les joueurs
arrivent à hot dight note là il y a 20
secondes contre 8
et je crois que a réussi à faire passer
un peu l'orage
faudrait qu'il arrive à changer une tour
ça serait cool
cavalier F1 il défend F2 mais ça ça a
l'air bizarre ce truc là tout rêve de F2
et ma news qui loue cette position ok je
pense ma lune n'est pas du tout du tout
du tout
en difficulté dans cette position ça
fait nul direct d'ailleurs ils sont même
pas chercher à se prendre la tête il y
avait quand même les vrais il y avait
deux pièces contre la tour mais il y
avait un pion de plus et dans ce format
là
cavalier fou ça gagne absolument jamais
cette c'est impossible
salut Sky Netflix salut à toi bonjour à
tous
alors fou à 4 a été joué donc là c'est
encore la même
une sorte d'espagnol avec four à 4 sans
qu'il y a 6 et curieux
alors je sais pas si quelqu'un dans le
chat peut nous expliquer l'idée de jouer
fou A4 sans qu'il est joué à 6
généralement on attend peut-être qu'il a
pris move je sais pas généralement quand
on joue au B5 quand même on joue à
quatre quand le pion arrive en A6
normalement après ok je sais pas un
spécialiste du tout de ces positions
mais ça me paraît quand même assez
curieux cette décision
ça me paraît curieux
x 4 pour jouer C3 sur cahier de 4
ok c'est à dire qu'ici si je joue pas ça
j'aurais regardé des 4 et on échange des
pièces ok c'est peut-être le cas
peut-être la raison pourquoi on joue foi
à 4 en tout cas François Jacques je sais
que c'est position de italienne et
espagnol toutes ces
petites
détails là
je la connais pas tout pas trop ok H6
direct peut-être avec prise et le 5 je
sais pas si c'était possible donc là on
va jouer quand même le même le même même
chez MAC tout à l'heure en skyril
cavalier 3 avec un D4 un moment donné ça
risque d'être
le truc donc des 4 a été joué ou des 7
il y a plusieurs plusieurs manières de
jouer un H3
G6 alors D5 c'est une possibilité mais
après ce fou il sera pas forcément très
bon ça qu'on pourra aller changer contre
le four en DS7 ton Jacques fou c'est de
plutôt je veux cavalier G3
donc c'est possible qu'ils sont quand
même très très souples pour les blancs
il y a plein de possibilités à chaque
fois
et noir qui ont choisi un schéma du
style est indien pour cette position
ok je trouve va être le coup pour les
blancs prochain coup
souvent un cador on peut jouer plus on
prend les D5 je sais pas si c'est
possible là une réaction centrale prise
des cinq pour mettre un Cavaillon E4 si
je prends ici je gagne la paire de fou
mais je perd un pion je sais pas si
c'est possible j'en sais rien du tout
mais c'est une prise et des cinq c'est
une une
réaction assez normale dans ces
positions c'est la finale c'est la
grande finale du speech
la grande finale entre Magnus Carlsen et
Hikaru Nakamura
et les deux joueurs qui ont qui ont un
petit peu survolé l'événement je pense
que Naka a eu un gros match quand même
il faut quand même souligner le gros
match qui a une inca contre la
contrainte VL et c'est pas du tout
c'était pas simple du tout mvl qui a
failli créer la surprise
il était devant il a commencé à mener
3-0 en 5 + 1 après il se fait rattraper
mais à la fin des 3 + 5 il menait plus
un dans le score et on y croyait un sa
victoire ambulette n'a qu'à a été juste
trop fort en fait c'est dur de de jouer
hyper bien pendant trois heures en
Bullet tu peux complètement complètement
craqué et en face ça commet très peu de
fautes et ça joue hyper vite ça m'a la
pression autant c'est vrai que Naka il
est très très dur à jouer
que B3 avec les jouets c'est 5 ça c'est
bizarre ce cavalie au bord mais écoutez
avec vous c'est 5 est-ce que ici il y a
pas comme D5 pour priver le cava et la
casse C6 est-ce que c'est possible
descendre juste positionnellement je te
dis bah écoute ton cavalier je joue pas
je comprends pas trop
vous m'expliquer où est-ce que ce
qu'avait dit va aller après comme dessin
moi j'aurais fait des scènes tous les
jours je sais pas je peux vous en pensez
mais j'aurais fait des 5 tous les jours
je leur ai beaucoup d'avant là je le
refais encore
parce que
[Musique]
je sais pas trop ce qu'on fait sur D5
peut-être il attendait 5 parce qu'il
veut jouer à un schéma du style est
indienne avec F5 à un moment donné et
pour jouer F5 dans les positions très
souvent et ben on va attendre vraiment
que la position soit fermée je peux pas
jouer à 5 comme ça quand il y a plein de
pression au centre soit je dois attendre
que ça se ferme pour jouer F5
et ok bon dame deux a été joué et là on
vis-à-vis de la tour c'est pas
recommandé généralement mais on va voir
un peu quel milieu de Magnus
qui existe le 5 cavale 5 et là on va
changer finalement et on l'avait pas de
structure un petit peu de Benoni après
ca va les prendre gaval et prend en
souffrant cette structure là c'est un
peu la structure Bénoni dans ses
positions
je sais pas si vous avez vu si vous avez
vu le petit short qui a été créé par par
chestcom Fr le petit short de Fab Libye
sur la bédonie je vous conseille d'aller
voir ça vous marquez bedonitescom fr sur
Youtube vous allez voir le petit short
de
le petit short de Libye
pour voir ce qu'il pense de la bénédonie
de la bonne et la mauvaise Bénoni
alors tour E5 a été joué
F4 il y a plusieurs coins intéressants
damassis on va manger le pion à 7
il y aura un faux point H3 mais je peux
aussi manger à 7 on peut se voir un
frais manger tous les pions mais depuis
on mange trois caméléon
qui pour arriver
sur le long terme
je suis d'accord avec toi un éco Games
je pense que que ça pourrait être plus
juste
parce qu'il y a des matchs je sais pas
si vous avez vu si vous avez vu le le
match Magnus contre sceaux et il a gagné
22 16 il a pas rendu il a pas perdu une
seule partie en dans les deux cadences
de Blitz franchement incroyable quoi au
bout de déjà premier set il y avait
combien il y avait 7 ans au premier set
je crois franchement le mal c'est que
déjà terminé tu joues contre manuscrite
je pense ah bon quoi en vrai mais bon
c'est horrible quoi
je pense que au bout d'une heure il y a
plus de match quoi fallait enfin juste
ça peut intérêt de continuer quoi c'est
vrai que c'est pour ça que je pense que
les jeux par 7 c'est intéressant parce
que ok tu percettes
quoi c'est un peu comme au tennis quoi
tu prends 6-0 premiers 7 bah ok bah
maintenant on fait le deuxième 7 et puis
je peux revenir quoi donc je trouve que
c'est intéressant de changer cette
formule mais bon c'est comme ça depuis
longtemps et je pense pas que cheescom
soit prêt à changer de suite je pense F5
qui est naturel
du pion pour jouer F5
pour livrer la case pour les pièces là
ouais c'est thématique
il est pas mal en vrai en vrai il est il
est très très sympa ce petit short
on est on était au commentaire de je
sais plus quel événement
je sais plus quelle est cette
on a bien rigolé ouais
manuscrit encore mieux autant encore une
fois il a plus d'une minute d'avance
maca qui est pas content de sa position
il prend son petit sa petite tasse de
thé là ou de café je sais pas ce qui
boit
cavalier 4
tout va vite
fouger 5 est-ce que c'est un coup il
fait 6
ça a l'air le coup j'ai envie de la
tempo F6 je sais pas si ça va être ça va
aller
passer ce que Magnus veut faire
bref
ça a l'air beaucoup trop fort il faut le
que c'est fou F4 à la sympa aussi hein
mais
il faut les cinq c'est le coup numéro 1
j'ai l'impression en tout cas d'un point
de vue humain ça a l'air puisque quand
tu fais F6 et ben tu bloques toutes tes
pièces ou F4 deux points d'interrogation
c'était mon coup
c'était mon goût je suis désolé Magnus
fallait pas m'écouter
c'était mon idée on prend tout mais je
bouge pas énormément avec les noirs
waouh faut assise qu'est-ce qui se passe
là tour reprend si tu prends là je
prends 8
et attention Magnus qui gagne une pièce
je crois parce que je m'en fous prends
là je prends là si on compte les pièces
moi j'ai quand même manger à une troupe
que toi j'ai une tour de plus sur
celle-là et tu prends là je prends là il
y a plus d'échec il y a plus il y a pas
d'échec il y a pas de prise qui sont en
prises c'est complètement terminé je
crois d'ailleurs je n'ai pas mis le
score un jour mettre maintenant le score
à jour j'ai oublié que je vais mettre le
score à chaque fois dans toutes ces
[Musique]
arnaques il y a 0,5
pendant que Magnus est à un point et
demi
ce qui prend le lead dans ce match et je
pense que franchement
Magnus il peut avoir vraiment un edge
dans ces cadences de 5 + 1 parce que bon
c'est quand même un meilleur joueur
d'échec que Nakamura ça c'est ça c'est
clair
c'est pas c'est pas un peintre mais
d'ailleurs désolé c'est des peintres
dans le chat c'est une expression
mais mais oui c'est un très bon joueur
c'est un très très bon joueur mais bon
Magnus c'est Magnus quoi un champion du
monde c'est peut-être même le meilleur
joueur de toute l'histoire donc
franchement
ok D4 j'aime beaucoup ce coup D4 j'aime
beaucoup ce coup des quatre alors très
souvent ce coup des quatre ça sert
regarder à gagner sur le long terme la
case des quatre par exemple tu joues un
coup voilà peut-être on peut manger là
celui de prise et de B4 et l'idée en
fait je montre rapidement l'idée après
on revient sur la partie prise B4 une
fois que tu bouges ce pion et ben je lui
ai manqué 4 et mon cavalier c'est un
monstre cette case là donc c'est guider
à ces stratégique très intéressante
et
a gagné 5 années de suite j'ai cru lire
quelque part robinsight que en
SCCC
en SCCC et ben
Magnus mène deux ans
quand on a qu'à
après je sais qu'ils sont je l'année
dernière
et que Naka a battu mvl abattu un Magnus
en finale
14-13 et demi je crois
et après Magnus un moment donné il joue
plus les speeds pendant quelques temps
regardez il a fait l'idée il a fait ça
avec etb4 il veut récupérer ça le SCCC
c'est le speed Chester
en G4 et maintenant pas la question
comment est-ce que tu vas défendre ce
pion en G4 bon je pose toujours manger
aussi c'est toujours un coup
il joue cavalier il va donner ici mais
s'il prend l'attention il y a un petit
tactique je crois faut prendre un S7
regardez paf paf paf paf et je peux plus
défendre le fou G4 c'est l'idée de
dikaru qui va mettre le cavalier du coup
en E3 et réussir à quand même garder le
contrôle de la case des 5 donc là il va
y avoir une petite bataille sur la case
les blancs qui mettent les pièces sur la
case blanche casse des 5 par exemple et
en contraste Magnus qui va peut-être
jouer sur la case Descartes sur le long
terme mais tant que le Fou est là le fou
pourra s'échanger contre le cavalier le
rêve serait qui est plus de fou ici pour
pouvoir vraiment gagner le contrôle de
la case T4 à 100% mais du coup là j'ai
envie de donner une tête une bonne
position pour
pour Dakar un prix qui avait le droit
j'en ai pas malin il faut prendre
cavalier ici donc là manger après la
prise là il est vrai que je n'ai plus
l'accès à la case 3 à ton cavalier
prise
qui est oursin peut-être j'imagine un
truc comme ça avec cavalier 2 cavaler
ses quatre peut-être une idée aussi un
truc cavalier sur une belle case en C4
j'aime beaucoup cette idée là attention
ça marche pas un stylet de manger ici
manger ici
mais là j'aime bien ce coup-là mais bon
là faut voir attends c'est deux c'est
chaud
j'aime pas trop donner l'activité aux
pièces noires comme ça donc il est tombé
un tour B7 intéressant l'idée de Magnus
enfin les guides Naka pardon c'est pas
ma news des fois on a le droit de faire
des bons coups aussi
comment est-ce que je continue alors
ça fait peur vous voyez un truc comme ça
il y a toujours ton PC
ça peut être compliqué là je comprends
comment je descends quand je défends ici
mais fais attention à ce titre là
et du coup c'est quoi la rêve comment je
défends en fait je prends là je prends
là que je fais ça
canal et des deux est un coup tu prends
plus je viens là mon cavalier
peut-être c'est ça l'hiver
on va voir un peu ce qu'ils vont faire
c'est la partie ok bon on va le savoir
en tout cas parce que je me pose la
question et d'un premier set oui c'est
effectivement possible dans ma tête le
fou défendait encore B7 mais en fait non
c'était pas vrai merci pour d'apprendre
B7
mais maintenant si je veux retrouver
cette maintenant oui regardez sur un
prank je cavaliers
donc ça va arriver
ça va arriver peut-être maintenant
est-ce que c'est malin ou pas j'en ai
aucune idée peut-être c'est quoi le
temps débile mais bon ça fait une menace
c'est plus simple pas mettre ramener une
tour avec gain de temps soit 7e
visu là ça a l'air assez intéressant ce
petit coup ce petit couteau en B7 je
sais pas si ça va être ça va être joué
Kanaka et clairement qui il voit tout ce
qui est tactique ça mais peut-être que
mon coup est juste pas bon en fait
au tour de cette a été je dois regarder
c'est un coup brillant les gars c'est un
coup brillant
je crois que ça va tout dire les gars ça
veut tout dire
tourbé 7
qu'est-ce qu'on fait je crois que c'est
tout rouge bah j'ai cavalier aussi en
fait tout simplement avec un point là
faut H4
qu'est-ce qui se passe là Magnus
voilà jauge qui est quand même qui aime
bien les noirs et moi je va tomber cette
avec brillance un peu peur
roi et fuite ouais mais il faut avoir
envie de le faire tu te mets envisager
fuite je m'attends en prison maintenant
après c'est prêt après avoir fuite j'ai
plus
j'ai comme il y a plus d'échec là dans
ma tour devient en prison
ouais ça doit être un coup
c'est la partie j'ai pas de cavalier ça
a été joué
qui est intéressant
qui est tombé ici a été joué
qui a réussi à se défendre quand même
l'impression que c'était pas simple du
tout pour se défendre
mais il est pas content Magnus
de tout il va me faire une petite
[Musique]
tête là
ah mais le laisser il a laissé
il y a pas un tour G8 c'est ça
tournevite a été joué et ouais si on va
prendre la cavalier F6 exactement le
terme qu'on avait tout à l'heure proposé
avec
avec le vis-à-vis de la main attention
Magnus qui a qui tient de craquer
complètement cette position je pense
qu'elle est gagnante si on arrive à
manger le pion en à 6
si je mangeais pas le pion ainsi ça
pourrait presque être une une forteresse
en cette position
vous voyez si on enlève ses pions là je
pense ça peut faire nul avec les Noirs
parce que des pions blancs peuvent pas
vraiment passer je pense serait mieux le
direct
mais bon un problème c'est que le pur
insiste il va tomber sûrement non il
faut réussir à le manger quand même
genre ça si je fais ça et ça
peut peut-être faire un nul comment je
le mange ce pion peut-être ça
mais sur ça sans
ça
empêcher ça
je sais pas avoir en tête c'est le cas
il y en a 5 j'aime pas du tout les tours
et comment tu passes maintenant
qui est qui est qui
c'est vraiment le coup tu sais vraiment
le couteau C6 enfin ça a été joué
ok voilà je pense c'est que c'est nul
c'est bizarre ça a l'air quand même
enfantin genre je l'ai vu tempo je l'ai
vu tempo alors ça montre à quel point
c'était facile
en fait c'est interdent
c'est impardable tout est défendu
tout est défendu il va jouer cette fois
F6 et il va faire aller-retour
essuie-glace monsieur
les Blancs ne peuvent pas passer ok mais
bon ça sert à rien enfin la position F4
je mange tout
je mange tout tu pourras plus pousser ça
tu pourras pas je pense c'est
complètement nul
complètement nul salut à tous sur le
chat salut root
salut pognard salut ceux qui viennent
d'arriver
il y a zéro idée
je pense un prix move pourrait faire
perdre Magnus mais c'est tout
voilà voilà voilà mais en fait même avec
ma tour là
une idée ça pourrait être de passer et
d'essayer de s'agisser la dame sur
tourpion et pousser le pion
sans que le Fou est le temps de revenir
mais bon
c'est pas c'est pas un débile
par exemple le roi light dame B6 c'est
un peu tiré par les cheveux
mais bon
madame bêtise au pire des cas juste
j'attends je mange pas en fait
je vois pas du tout
[Rires]
il y a des petites idées qui pourraient
qu'on pourrait essayer de faire mais bon
à ce niveau-là
OK et ça fait nul dans cette partie
ouais
grosse grosse désillusion de de Naka qui
ne gagne pas cette partie qui était
archi archi gagnante pour lui je pense
qu'il va sans vouloir il aurait pu
égaliser dans ce match il aurait pu
arriver à
un et demi 1 et demi et au final bah
écoutez
57 minutes de 5 + 1 il y aura une pause
à la moitié à chaque fois il y a une
pause au
[Musique]
à 45 minutes donc là dans le corps
environ 10 minutes il y aura une pause
on peut imaginer qu'après cette partie
il y aura une pause je pense une peau de
5 minutes pour les joueurs
donc a été joué cavalier à 3
et donc là c'est une structure si vous
voulez de françaises d'échange
complètement symétrique donc ça c'est
assez égal mais les blancs être mieux
parce que les pièces sont mieux placées
ils ont plus d'espace que veut dire que
mal placé par exemple le besoin qui est
un peu plus de mal à se défendre le
cavalier F5 qui est là qui est bien mais
bon au final il est quand même pas si
bien placé que ça
donc souvent on va essayer de jouer sur
le pion des 5 dans cette position
avec l'avantage aussi d'espace dans
lequel j'ai 5 des fois dans bouge
c'est les positions ou les blancs
normalement ont zéro chance de perdre
mais peuvent essayer de pousser un petit
peu
G2
qui est
continuer F6 enfin ça prend les cartes
de cavaliers donc il y a plus de
cavaliers G5 cavaliers ici
je sais pas ce comment on continue cette
position cavale 3 ça fait des échanges
je sais pas si c'est vraiment l'idée de
Magnus je préfère ça il faut prendre par
exemple mais je sais pas si j'ai changé
des pièces va favoriser les blancs ici
ou pas
je pense que si Magnus
si Magnus ah il veut cavalier
[Musique]
je pensais qu'il voulait C4 donc il joue
avec prise il est sur cavalier prend
comment est-ce qu'on va jouer
enfin pendant que il est extrêmement
fort ambulette les manus aussi
et je sais pas vraiment je pense qu'il y
a parents de stratégie de match juste
les joueurs vont essayer de gagner toute
partie qui peuvent mais il y a pas
stratégie je pense chacun fait ce qui
peut
c'est à dire que je pense que ma venue
il peut gagner n'importe quelle partie
n'importe quel match comme Naka enfin
juste en fait les joueurs sont à peu
près ça match environ 50 50 sur toutes
les cadences
donc il y a pas de stratégie je pense
que vraiment que quand même que Magnus
est favori dans ce cadre de 5 + 1 mais
le reste en 3 + 1 et en Bullet je pense
franchement que
que
c'est assez égal quoi
donc je pense pas que que Naga
veuille absolument tout jouer angulette
je pense que il a de la chance dans tous
les cadences
exactement
donc il y a eu cavalier C3 de jouer
c'est vraiment parce que le fou était en
DC il me semble ouais donc il y a eu une
répétition 3
donc oui
c'est pour ça que
il y a pas de stratégie je pense que les
joueurs vont juste essayer de bien jouer
quoi
et je prends là et maintenant on a tous
les deux de notre pion isolé c'est une
position qui a l'air assez égal
et il reste
ouais tours
ok je pense il doit être joué ici
parce que c'est important de prendre la
colonne ah ça fait nul direct ok ok
encore une partie du coup avant la pause
je change encore le score je vais vous
changer le score ici
c'est pas pourquoi ils veulent qu'on
change de score manuellement ce qu'on
peut score il y a de l'afficha en bas
mais on m'a dit qu'il fallait le faire
alors je le fais mais en vrai vous
l'avez déjà affiché en bas le score
alors on part sur une autre espagnol
cette pollution elle a déjà vu tout à
l'heure
il y avait cavalier F1
et il y avait eu cavalier F1 fou aussi
il me semble
pour être sûr que je suis ouais c'est ça
il y avait eu ça ça alors
c'était quoi la partie comment ça avait
été
je sais plus comment vous avez le soleil
change l'ordre de quoi
OK
standard il joue à 4 à 4 c'est pour
ouvrir la colonne A à un moment donné
qui est fou aussi
que j'ai trois
[Musique]
aussi qui peut être une option
oui il s'appelle chemise pour l'occasion
pour l'occasion il avait la belle
chemise assortie avec sa petite lumière
derrière
quand j'étais en Espagne là il y a
quelques mois j'ai fait un magasin et il
vendait que des tous les T-Shirts enfin
tout ce qui vendait il y avait des
ananas c'est un truc de fou
mais quasiment tout ce que vous avez des
jeans des trucs qui veulent toujours
logo je crois que c'est je crois que
c'est le magasin de Naka mais c'était
assez marrant quoi
genre comment ça
ok dessin que tout à l'heure il y avait
eu une position un peu similaire où il y
avait un dame F3 qui a été joué et il y
avait eu T4 de la part de Magnus qui
avait été joué donc cette partie n'a
qu'à pas laisser un Magnus jouer des 4
donc qui prend en dessin
salut Manu
dame prend des cinq
et là maintenant on peut imaginer un
coup de style F3 ou pas
[Musique]
idée d'apprendre cavalier prendre ta
queue
et ici le noir en plus d'espace donc
peut-être changer une pièce ça fait pas
de mal j'aime bien la F3 après je sais
pas du tout
je sais pas du tout
[Musique]
ou pas qu'avec le 4 aussi de mettre un
coup ici
la prise en V5 je peux le faire un peu
quand je veux
donc voilà il attend il prend son temps
il y a cavalier F1 cavaliero 3
probablement
et
donc cavalier F1 est venu en E3 et F5
peut-être et P4 j'avais peur de secours
je sais pas s'il fallait manger ou pas
en B5 d'abord je me dis qu'un jour il
perd un problème sur la structure
d'option C3 D3
c'est plus intéressant bah je pense que
c'est le le gros gros mat en tout cas je
pense que c'est vraiment le gros match
tout le monde l'attend c'est le gros
derby
45 Hikaru
en speech c'est quand même le match
qu'on attend
c'est les deux meilleurs joueurs
d'Internet clairement et c'est pris une
grosse déculotté
clairement
so enfin Magnus avait l'avantage dans le
match je veux dire
clairement selon le bookmaker il était
lancé favoris c'est clair mais je
pensais pas qu'il allait lui mettre une
telle fessée quoi
parce que sauf ce qui m'a très très bon
joueur à se prendre 22,7 quand même
mais bon c'est ça va vite quand tu es
pas en forme dans un match et tout
contre un joueur qui est hyper en forme
tu perd une partie tu repères deux trois
la température de 18 en fait et c'est
trop dur quoi le pion c'est 4 a été
donné ok pour quelle raison est-ce que
le pion vient a été donné on va le
savoir peut-être maintenant
je fais pas la gueule il a l'air d'être
assez
content on a qu'à aussi
donc la paire de fou ok le cache blanche
peut-être c'est pour ça que peut-être
qu'il y a
il y a un peu de jeu pour
pour les blancs grâce à la paire de fou
mais bon un pion c'est un pion quand
même
ce pion on aurait pu le défendre mais
bon c'est moche
si je fais ça
un moment on va être perdu un moment
donné donc il a essayé de pas souffrir
juste il préfère rendre le pion garder
la barre de fou j'aime bien le coup à 5
qui est un jour pourra m'aider et ce
pion sur une case blanche qui peut pas
te défendre un jour peut-être
avec le four en C4 et mettre la pression
sur ce pion qui pourra jamais bouger
ça m'a l'air pas mal ce petit coup petit
coup à 5 qui peut arriver aussi il faut
surveiller un peu toutes les toutes les
possibilités mais dans l'idée c'est quoi
l'air pas mal
donc salut à tous ceux qui arrivent dans
le chat je peux pas tous vous répondre
un par un mais en tout cas je vous dis
tous bonjour
tour des 8
qu'est-ce que va jouer ici Caro
et je fous des trois donc à 5 c'est
moche après j'ai foulé 5 aussi mon fou
et mettre monstrueux peut-être qu'ils
avaient le temps de faire à 5 il a le
temps de presser sur l'option assise je
pense qu'à 5,5 qui sera jamais joué
voyez ça ça le fou il a des logeable il
est vraiment très fort donc on n'aura
jamais on verra jamais jamais à 5 et il
y a eu cavalier dessin qu'est-ce que je
peux jouer ici le coup
des deux pour défendre ici mais j'ai
peur qu'il cavalait des cavaliers B4
cavalier F4 gardez l'idée ce que je fais
j'essaye de gagner la paire de fou ça
aide d'échanger de gagner un fou
surtout lui qui est assez fort surtout
les trois
je sais pas
qu'il est possible de faire
et aussi ça qui peut être possible aussi
qui clou un peu le cavalier mais je
pense
tu prends la je prends en fait deux fois
ça marche quand même pas de jeu 4
j'ai pas trop les autres couilles et
tout c'est un qui donne le 3 ça c'est
quand même assez
assez incroyable donc après quand tu
donnes trois ok ta photo
à la longue ça peut quand même
ça peut se transformer en nul donc c'est
pas sûr du tout il y a un problème plus
pour la noire
de monter le roi sur case noire
généralement ici mettre tes pions sur 15
blanche aussi pour reprendre les cases
du fou je serais pas étonné de voir un
coup comme f54
après l'échange des tours ici est-ce que
ça va est-ce qu'il y a une chance de
gain pour pour Magnus c'est pas clair
non
mais je vous décides
c'est le bon coup pour essayer de jouer
je pense qu'on a besoin
si on avait échangé comme ça parce que
en fait je vois ici je veux ça ça
et là tu passes jamais et puis là tout
va se changer
ça a l'air nul assez facile donc pour
cette gagner il faut garder les pièces
ok jouer F5 quand même donc les blancs
qui doivent enfin les Noirs qu'il avait
essayé de se créer un peu passé et là il
Caron qui a réussi à faire son petit
blocus 115 blanche
j'aime bien fou ces quatre
il y a eu ici HK donc tournage est bien
sûr tout le temps fou bien évidemment
je pense à quoi de mieux je pense ça va
faire nul ça va faire nul très vite je
vois pas trop comment
Magnus peut essayer de la jouer genre
limite il est moins bien en fait limite
c'est c'est blanc qui vont finir par
jouer quoi
parce que le foot casse blanche je suis
quand même beaucoup plus actif que le
cadre malgré le pion de moins
vous savez un futur imposé ce qui compte
le plus c'est pas forcément les pions
c'est la pièce
pour D7
mais bon ça ça ton G7
il y a même pas de match
on la joue même pas
ok il a joué
il va être le rond pour défendre ici
et le fou ici
et ça farnient même C4 va être joué par
les blancs ils vont faire nul direct
à moi qui s'est levé qui est parti Manu
ce qui est un peu déçu il a il a
peut-être le sentiment d'avoir raté un
truc dans cette partie peut-être qu'il
aurait pu
faire un peu mieux
et ça fait nul direct ok ben écoutez on
est à
3 2 je vais vous mettre le score à jour
3 2 pour Magnus dans ce match et pour
voir un petit peu à quel point c'est
serré ce match il y a eu une seule
partie
décisive dans ce match on est à 4 nuls
et une victoire de Magnus donc c'est
ultra Serien
ultra serré donc on fait une petite
pause comme les joueurs et on revient si
vous voulez dans 5 minutes pour pour la
fin de ce premier set avec pour
l'instant un
score de 3 2 en faveur de Magnus je vous
dis à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présence ciel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis de retour je suis de retour pour
la deuxième moitié du premier set qui va
reprendre la manquer quelques instants
donc on est à 3,2 on pour l'instant en
faveur de Magnus Magnus qui a gagné une
partie il y a eu 4 nuls et une victoire
pour l'instant de Magnus pour qu'on
marche très très serré
du monde championnat du monde avec
toutes ces nuls et donc un match qui
tient toutes ses promesses pour
l'instant la Camorra qui qui mange un
petit peu qui mange qui s'hydrate c'est
bien il faut le match qui dure très
longtemps trois heures de de Blitz et
Bullet c'est c'est assez c'est assez
intense comme match il faut pas se
laisser couler envoyer un Magnus qui
mène d'un point seulement ce match
gagné une autre partie ça pourrait faire
deux points d'avance ça pourrait déjà
bon il y a encore beaucoup à faire mais
avec deux points d'avance déjà on met la
pression sur un cas et
on pourrait mettre un troisième point
derrière etc c'est important
dans ce match
donc là ça devrait reprendre quand même
bientôt ma venue ce qui n'est pas encore
là
on a vu enfin moi j'ai vu sur les
camarades vous savez que les joueurs
doivent arriver normalement un petit
quart d'heure à l'avance pour enfin dans
le zoom pour régler les caméras avoir le
temps un peu tout faire et tout
simplement
tout simplement Magnus il est arrivé à
donc il a pas respecté ça et nous on l'a
attendu attendu sur le sur le zoom là
c'est pareil on va on va reprendre
on va reprendre le le mat et il n'est
pas là près d'arriver je sais pas
elle est magnifique
les joueurs sont prêts pour en découdre
dans cette deuxième partie
de premier set salut ciel bleu
et j'ai pas encore si c'est la partie
qui s'affiche et ça commence
prédiction à payer non c'est les
prédictions c'est à la fin du 7
c'est la fin du set qu'on paye les
musiciens Torpen
et encore 42 minutes et 35 secondes vous
voyez en haut à gauche
le petit temps qui s'écoule arrivait à
zéro le 7 sera terminé et on passera à
une heure de trois plus simples et
ensuite une demi-heure de un plus un
alors P6 a été joué
ça c'est une ligne qui est intéressante
souvent il y a du dessin rapide qu'on
peut jouer avec les Blancs
après je suis pas un expert mais je sais
que des seins qui est des il y a plein
d'idées avec des seins qui peuvent se
jouer très vite et Magnus qui a préféré
jouer un truc assez simple avec ici à 3
et il a laissé les Noirs à revenir ici
on peut espérer jouer 4 prochainement
fou de rock et vite sortir les pièces
tranquillement à 1000 fois en Détroit
plutôt peut-être espoir alors taper sur
H7 et là qui finit je sais pas ce qu'il
mange et qui finit son petit dessert
avant c'est un petit gâteau au chocolat
un petit coulant je sais pas ce qu'il
mangeait mais ça avait pas l'air mauvais
à retourner
donc comment est-ce qu'on peut jouer
c'est que les blancs
il y a un coup qui m'a l'air intéressant
mais je sais pas trop j'ai peur de dire
des coups qui sont vraiment pas bon
je pense que mon cou est quand même
vraiment pas bon je pensais
pour essayer d'ouvrir un peu le fou et
si un jour votre cavalier en gs5 un truc
comme ça mais
pas génial un peu trop simple qui aura
du prises
et cavaler ses 6 et j'ai un petit
problème sur l'option ici peut-être dame
je sais pas trop mais avoir en tout cas
si s'il y a des coups
trouve plus confiant que l'autre jour ah
bah l'autre jour était venu 3-0 dans ce
premier set les Garous donc c'est clair
quand tu aimes les 3-0 tu es pas
confiant tu es pas confiant mais
mais du coup ouais non là il est quand
même mené
que d'un point mais contre malus Carson
c'est le gros derby de l'année ce match
alors tourner un a été joué on va
défendre tes 4 c'est la surprotection on
appelle ça
et ensuite il faut continuer à sortir
les pièces donc on sait pas comment on
va comment on va on va s'y prendre
avec cavalier prend et c'est de ramener
une pièce là haut genre la dame
même
un petit peu
boire un petit peu ce qui va nous faire
en tout cas là
prise prise qui va être ses salaires
standard mais j'ai peur que plus tard il
y a un problème tour c'est un qui peut
arriver il y a eu H6 vous voyez je sais
pas si c'est en prévision de fouger 5
qui avait l'air assez intéressant mon
couple peut-être que
peut-être que mon coup lui a fait peur
non
mais aussi full beauté je sais pas si un
jour on va réussir à on va réussir à
ouvrir cette diagonale c'est pas clair
parce que quand vous B2 il joue un coup
C4 il va manger là et j'ai l'impression
que tout pourri et peut-être des cinq
mais si jamais j'arrive à faire dessin
que ces quatre c'est génial mais descend
qui va pas me laisser faire comme ça il
va me manger un jour le pion et je pense
pas que de sacrifice pour l'instant pour
ouvrir le fou donc j'aime pas trop fou
B2 plutôt fou au 3 du coup elle joue
tous les deux ok bon intéressant en tout
cas parce que faut dire c'est ça peut
marcher si on arrive à le dessin
parce que le fou ne pourra plus manger
en des cinq champions
c'est quoi ce que j'avais réussi j'avais
réussi à trouver l'idée de ça et ça mais
je n'arrivais pas le mettre en place et
en fait c'est simple après coup B2 les
non pas beaucoup de coup d'offre sur le
cavalier et quand le noir bouche le
cavalier et ben finalement les blancs
arrivent à jouer ce plan que j'avais
proposé depuis le début
ouais là c'est vraiment un classe fou B2
c'était le coup ou le fou était bloqué
par tous les pions mais il l'a joué
parce qu'il savait qu'il allait réussir
à pousser les pions devant c'est
vraiment grosse stratégie ça les joueurs
qui qui savent placer des pièces
et du coup là j'ai un pion passé
protéger
j'ai une belle position avec les blancs
très belle position
alors généralement contre un pion
passé protégé comme celui-ci le setup
des Noirs ce serait de mettre un
cavalier si possible en D6 qui avait les
bloqueurs on appelle ça parce que le
cavalier qui bloque un pion passé comme
ça et ben déjà ça bloque mais en plus ça
attaque les défenseurs
éventuels de de ce pion
et en plus donc en pleine position et
ben ça pourrait aussi provoquer des des
ruptures par exemple un jour chez mon
cavalier ici peut-être que A6 B5 peut un
jour être une idée pour essayer de
d'enlever ce pion et manger des cinq par
exemple
cavalier très fort ça bloque ça attaque
les gens qui défend et ça menace
éventuellement des ruptures
et bon match le cavalier c'est pas
facile faudrait bouger la tour
ça fait beaucoup de coups et pendant ce
temps les Blancs jouent les blancs vont
essayer de faire à 5 et jouer sur le
pion B6 qui est faible
donc tourba 8 a été joué
en tout cas rappelez-vous bien de de ce
pion passer protégé le meilleur bloqueur
c'est le cavalier
si vous avez le choix entre mettre une
dame ou un cavalier devant ce pion
peut-être cavalier c'est beaucoup mieux
que mettre une dame qui va se faire
attaquer par toutes mes pièces donc Dame
des deux très logique de la part de
Magnus il veut échanger les pièces parce
que tout simplement le pion passé ben il
va avancer regardez la dame qui vient on
peut imaginer un coup de dames un jour
un matin
j'aime beaucoup céder
cavalier
comment on joue quand la tension à ce
pion à ce plan ici
est-ce que tout reprend tout reprend et
tout va vite c'est possible
gardez je prépare je prépare la petite
tour ruine voilà
tac tac je sais plus qu'à faire ça et ça
et j'aurais réussi mon setup et qu'avec
qui va venir avec le fou attaquer ce
pion C4 c'est un contre jeu qui pourrait
éventuellement arriver bah lui il a pas
forcément de raison de manger un 8 oui
il a jeté
quand même pas mal les noirs pour
arriver au setup de rêve
et qu'elle sentait un peu peur quand
même je vois tous les vis-à-vis ça me va
me faire F4 d'être le coup pour bien
fixer le cavalier en E5 pour pas qu'il
soit déstabilisé et pour aussi gagner un
petit peu de liberté avec mes pièces
parce que là par exemple
F4 pour pouvoir bouger madame
pas bête du tout et aussi Kamel c'est 6
qui est une idée assez intéressante
aussi un qui pourrait être taquiner un
petit peu le pion à 7
j'aime bien les blancs décidément il y a
ce plan de 5 qui est extrêmement fort
ici
je ne sais pas
est-ce que j'entendais de le faire
difficilement est-ce que vous entendez
le bruit ou pas du tout
car ici ça a été joué
donc finalement et tous les pions en
fait sont faibles
un peu ouais bon ça va pas durer très
longtemps de façon
mais je sais pas ce qui
je sais pas ce qu'il fait
enfin de septembre en Espagne est-ce que
vous savez
OK
là ça pète hein
là c'est la pluie là c'est la pluie de
la pluie d'artifice
c'est même plus un feu c'est la pluie
qui est fou à 4 vous voyez la cavalier
qui est venue en 8 hein il va réussir le
set up
sauf que maintenant waouh
là je pense à mon chat mon chat il
déteste ça il a très très peur de faire
des fils
très très peur
en fait il se dit que les Blancs
pourront jamais sortir la dame noire
d'ici
elle est rentrée comment ça elle a la
maison mais moi je suis je suis caché
dans le bureau parce que sinon elle
vient jouer avec les cartes de
l'ordinateur et ça c'est pas c'est pas
très cool
quand je stream généralement je j'ai du
mal à la garder avec moi dans le
le dans le bureau quoi
ouais
d'accord et
[Musique]
ça marche
mais du coup du coup est-ce qu'il y a
aussi un des chez vous parce que c'est
juste en fait
après là où j'habite il y a souvent des
des trucs organisés des concerts et tout
il s'élève plein de choses chez moi
3 4 5 je sens qu'il a été joué donc sur
quasiment bien sûr
cette position si les Noirs arrivent
vraiment à avoir leur set up
si j'arrive à faire ça et ça je peux
limiter le mieux avec les noirs
mais mettre un cavalier en dessin c'est
extrêmement dur à faire
damla la dame
ça ça
serait une bonne une bonne idée
dame qui c'est mieux mais en plus le fou
sur case blanche il fait rien si moi je
vais sur quasiment et que je me place
dans le fou il peut être très vite
inutile c'est pour ça que que je trouve
cette position si jamais les Noirs
arrivent à mettre le plan en marche ça
peut vraiment être très très bon pour
les noirs
et bon pas clair que tu arrives à que tu
arrives à Mathieu cavalier oui il y a
toujours foutrant des blancs sur la
terre d'échanger je pense que si les
blancs arrivent à échanger les blancs
sont peut-être juste gagné en fait pas
sur sa gagne mais bon j'ai l'impression
que Madame il y a moyen quand même que
je mette la pression
mais ici regardez cavaliers je suis
cloué
OK
qui est fuite OK
donc il a troqué ce pion passé contre
l'autre passé et maintenant il joue
actif comme ça c'est 5
que des 4 je sais pas si vous avez vous
aussi des cours ralentis chez moi le
coup sont un peu ralenti des fois c'est
bizarre
je sais pas pourquoi
attention que les blancs vont finir par
gagner maintenant il y a la pression
cavalier ici il y a des pions qui
poussent là non puis on prend d'un point
et dames et victoire de Magnus
deuxième victoire de Magnus dans ce
match et ça fait maintenant un petit
plus deux
dans ce match de
asaram c'est pas chez c'est pas que chez
moi ok
je pensais que l'erreur était chez moi
j'ai eu un petit un petit doute ça peut
arriver ce matin j'ai un problème
internet j'ai du Tour de marée la box ça
marchait après quand j'ai fait un appel
Skype
et ils m'ont dit que ma collection était
trop lente pour que je fasse un appel
Skype je dis watts je la fibre quand
même
et donc là bon je me suis un peu
inquiété pour ce soir quand même je me
suis dit si jamais si jamais
[Musique]
j'ai pas internet ça va être grave pour
le stream mais au final ça c'est quand
même bien fait
ralenti ouais mais quand tu as un cours
ralenti et après un coup tempo prime
mauvais qui va très vite c'est bizarre
quoi genre la limite quand ça ralenti
tout terrain tout est ralenti c'est
mieux quoi faire la moitié des cours
ralenti alors tours ça couche super
bizarre mais bon C4 peut être une idée
de la part de la cas
qu'elle va aller prendre souffrante
ok on va revenir avec le fou quand même
on va pas échanger
ce cavalier
alors vous aussi d'être un coup
peut-être
mais les blancs veulent ces quatre
prochains courants
il veut manger là et taper son pion sur
deux
mais avoir en tout cas les gars ou qui
se fait pour l'instant à malmené quatre
ou deux en faveur de Magnus mais ça on
l'avait quand même dit je pense que
Magnus est favori dans ces cadences de
de
Blitz en 5 + 1 après plus ça s'accélère
plus Naka commence à pouvoir devenir
chiant mais bon si Magnus est vraiment
en forme comme il a montré dans tous ses
matchs de speechess ça va être dur
pendant quand même ma news qui fait un
excellent tournoi il est vraiment
intraitable
il a montré l'autre fois encore contre
saw 1 il a gagné 22 à 7
sauf pour le bas de 22,7 quand même il
faut y aller soit normalement c'est un
des favoris de ce événement ceux qui a
de la battu plein de fois des joueurs
comme Naka comme comme Magnus aussi dans
différents tournois online c'est
vraiment un joueur qui qui pouvait créer
l'exploit et 22 à 7 c'est quand même un
peu l'humiliation quand même
donc malus il est extrêmement
extrêmement en forme extrêmement chaud
et
[Musique]
et donc en grande forme tout à huit a
été joué
est-ce que que se passe
est-ce que je rate quelque chose
peut-être
je rate quelque chose de noir enfin je
vois la chose qui aime pas du tout mon
cou j'arrive pas encore à comprendre
pourquoi
peut-être juste
faut prendre et
du mal à comprendre
ouais non
c'est quoi juste je veux savoir
cavalier F4 ah ok pardon
G6 waouh c'est fort quand même
comprendre que ça donne un pion en fait
tu peux tu peux le voir et tu peux
comprendre cette idée là mais là juste
faire tour à 8 et de dire vas-y prends
le pion je m'en fous moi je te mate
tempo c'est quand même assez monstrueux
ou pas parce que bon moi je vous dis moi
le pion je le mange temporaire je mange
et après je réfléchis
en tout cas en blitz je pense plus
réfléchis en partie lente j'aurais
peut-être réfléchi un petit peu plus
mais
en [__] comme ça
mais là un peu en plus comme c'est un
blitz
et ben on a un peu des fois le sentiment
que l'adversaire peut se tromper qui
peut y avoir un oubli
donc on a tendance à vouloir payer pour
voir
et maintenant fort
les joueurs les joueurs qui qui peuvent
se voir à la caméra
[Musique]
vous voyez Magnus qui regarde un petit
peu en haut à droite je pense que c'est
là qu'il voit
dans sa caméra qu'il a placé Magnus sur
son écran
les joueurs qui peuvent se voir pendant
le match
je pense c'est bien de se voir c'est
comme un peu quand on joue on joue au TB
over the board
on a besoin des fois de voir
l'adversaire voir ses réactions voir
tout ça et sur Internet on n'a pas ses
réactions mais là dans ce match là ils
ont ils ont mis en place le système de
caméra ou les joueurs eux-mêmes peuvent
se peuvent se voir
4 je sais pas il y a comme ça en prison
à faire attention à ta roi
un coup il y a eu des dessins de jouets
ok bien ce coup de 5 la 4 éventuellement
un tour qui pourra aussi passer via A6
A2 à 3 et donne un pion quand même s'il
prend la tête et je mange là
tu peux enlever mais en fait
[Musique]
je peux vous dire que quand tu le vois
en caméra en train de se décomposer ça
fait plaisir parce que il fait tellement
le malin que que ça fait plaisir de le
voir un peu se décomposer donc je pense
que tu peux le laisser un petit peu et
si vraiment ça se passe mal pour toi et
ben tu coupes la caméra d'un gars parce
qu'il a insupportable mais que ça se
passe bien et ben tu peux tu peux le
garder quoi donc je pense intéressant en
tout cas Magnus je pense qu'il a gardé
parce que je pense qu'il s'en fout
complètement
et je suis pas sûr que je suis pas sûr
que
que le malin contre malgré lui dans son
premier map de de speechers contre
youngui il a joué à trois B3 à C3 et
tous les coups comme ça après
tout ça et que noir il joue à 5 à tous
les coups toutes les parties
[Musique]
c'est qu'il a pas droit mais bon il va
sûrement faire un truc comme ça un A4 si
jamais il mène de trois quatre points
quand Magnus il peut le faire juste pour
quitter un peu pour provoquer un peu son
adversaire il est comme ça il a bien la
provoque c'est un streamer c'est un
joueur qui qui fait son show donc je
pense que il pourrait faire un petit
truc comme ça bon là il est mignon au
score de deux points il va jamais faire
à 5 ou quoi que ce soit là il a vraiment
essayé de jours d'échecs et de revenir
un peu au score donc avec G5 j'aime bien
pour mettre le Cavalaire 4 c'est à dire
et la tour gagnant un peu des cases
mais bon il y a sur ce vis-à-vis faire
attention à ça
mais pour avoir réagi n'est pas réagi à
quoi martial
à quoi il avait réagi
qu'il y a eu tourcesseur donc là je peux
manger des cinq
bon le dessin qui ici
comment est-ce qu'il va continuer sur la
tête que juste tour à 7
je sais pas si ça suffit un truc comme
ça je peux manger ici mais je peux pas
tout en C7 et 5 ça peut faire mal
qui avait pris en B4
en fait déjà de base même c'est un
joueur qui a plus de 2700 c'est un
excellent joueur
donc même faire ça a eu c'est chaud
mais après bon on est beau c'est ça fait
deux fois d'affilée qu'il est venu
champion du monde
pareil c'est un moment donné tu peux pas
faire ça comme tout le monde quoi il y a
des joueurs que bon
je peux pas quoi juste
respecter un peu voyage fuite de Magnus
esthétique
pour défendre
passif avec une pièce il met la pièce
qui sert vraiment à rien en H8 en disant
bon au moins celle-là elle peut faire
plus tard
donc à T4
ok prise donc tant qu'à faire ce pion il
allait tomber il a préféré les changer
avant de le perdre
j'ai peur de se caler j'ai 5 qui peut
arriver
peut-être fou j'ai qu'avait de 5 ça a
l'air très très fort je pense que vous
voyez la position d'un égal on voit
vraiment la jauge qui donne égalité moi
j'aime pas les noirs
la pression que c'est pour les blancs
tellement facile à jouer
je pense ça peut être égal si les noirs
des fois dans la perfection mais ça
parce qu'il a tout vu mais en tant que
cumin avec 15 secondes à la pendule ça
m'a l'air extrêmement dur à jouer en
tout cas
qui a trouvé une ressource une ressource
et malgré tout ça reste dur encore pour
les pour les blancs
tomber vite changer une paire de tour ok
garde
attention on se met mal au temps ici
qu'avec il va venir en F4
voilà c'est pas quoi faire non c'est pas
comment
progresser dans la position prise
qu'avec il va venir en F3 D4 il y a 6
et il mange le pion des 4 ok voilà ça va
faire nul je pense pas que ça va jouer
je pense bientôt
[Musique]
ce qui va essayer de la jouer 5 je pense
pas
c'est moi de nouveau
tout échec attention il y a un clouage
ça peut des fois jouer en faveur des
Noirs histoire parce que maintenant les
pièces sont un petit peu
bloquer ok là il y a un blocus qui a été
fait kg
comment est-ce qu'on fait nul ici avec
attention attention
il y a un réseau là
j'ai pas cette pièce malheureusement il
manque le roi
il manque le roi
quand il parle comme ça on sait pas
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là dans les
gars ça a été extrêmement lent j'ai pas
vu ce qui s'est passé en tout cas ça a
quand même échangé
face à manger des pions en tout cas chez
Magnus et Magnus qui complètement
dégoûté
donc cette position en fait elle va
jouer pendant longtemps
parce que ce qui va se passer c'est que
si jamais
si jamais les blancs arrivent à manger
les pions ici c'est une finale qui est
théoriquement nulle mais qui est très
très dur à tenir en pratique surtout
avec peu de temps la pendule
je pense ça peut faire nul facile parce
que je vois pas trop comment les blancs
peuvent venir manger des pions aussi
facilement
mais je sais pas comment ils allaient
faire arnaquer
écoutez bon ça reste nul encore parce
que même si il perd l'option FC
mais est-ce qu'il va réussir à défendre
cette finale avec peu de temps la
pendule c'est final qui est très dur en
pratique on dit que environ 2400 hello
il y a à peu près
on va dire 60% de chance de faire nuit
le bas
le reste c'est bien blanc c'est horrible
c'est une finale qui qui est extrêmement
dur à tenir en pratique
moi j'avais réussi à tenir une fois une
fois en partie de cette finale je
l'avais fait nul mais je savais pas
comment vous avez dire j'ai fait un peu
au hasard j'ai trouvé une manière de
défendre c'était à très longtemps
mais
c'est pas évident du tout
qui aurait 5 les bouts sont toujours au
ralenti ça me fait peur
c'est courant
même le temps il se fige je sais pas si
vous voyez hein ça va de deux et je vois
un coupé 15 secondes ouais c'est trop
bizarre
trop bizarre ce temps je crois que les
gars
i attention aux petites blagues comme ça
avec une course
et il fallait absolument que j'y aille
donc j'ai plusieurs côtés impôts pour
gagner un peu de temps à la pendule et
me donner au moins deux trois minutes
pour y aller sinon ça aurait pu être la
catastrophe
c'était contre un grand maître
waouh ok les gars il s'est passé un truc
là il y a eu je pense 20 coups de jouets
d'un coup ouais ça bug complet ça bug
complet
ça bloque complet
en fait c'est
pareil tout le monde c'est pareil c'est
tout le monde
c'est comme bug complet
je sais pas ce que je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé je sais pas si ça fait nul
ou pas apparemment ça a gagné pour NACA
enfin je vois que la jauge elle est
comme ça et je rigole tous les deux on a
quand même l'air content donc c'est un
content de
[Musique]
voir si je peux
j'actualise mais je crois que j'ai perdu
les gars et ça a gagné dans cette
position et Magnus qui s'est laissé
tomber autant ok on va essayer de
revenir dans le match hop
ça a gagné ça a gagné pour Naka donc je
vais rajouter le score le point de Naka
oups 23 non ça fait trois
et maintenant on va commencer de partir
non moi non plus ben j'ai l'impression
qu'il a
c'est trop bizarre mais après on avait
le crank enfin les coups qui étaient
ralenti etc on a plein de retard j'ai
pas un chat à comprendre mais je crois
qu'il a donné une pièce je sais pas
comment il a fait
et même après ça annule était quand même
assez
assez logique tout de même il a perdu
cette finale plusieurs fois Magnus
bon en tout cas pour l'intérêt du match
c'est cool
on a qu'à qui revient à un point sur
Magnus
donc c'est cool donc faut 3 on voit
qu'il joue quand même souvent les mêmes
structures mais c'est jamais la même
position c'est toujours une Espagnole
différente c'est toujours des positions
différentes mais la structure par contre
c'est toujours la même et puis on a 4 la
production comme ça les cavaliers si
c'est toujours la même structure chez
les Blancs mais chez noir ça ça sent un
petit peu de setup à chaque fois
non mais je sais pas ce qu'il a fait
largement
il a mis tout en E4 je crois il a tout
le 5 défendait le cavalier enfin j'ai vu
ça en deux secondes pendant que ça
buggeait je sais pas si je me suis
trompé mais en tout cas il a donné
cavalier alors est-ce que c'était une
photo souris est-ce qu'il a pas vu le
cavalier est-ce qu'il a pensé qu'il
mangerait les pions
un peu sans raison
et d'un côté fou étroit
toutes les cases blanches ici
la Norvégienne
A5 le fameux coup à 5 le couple on a vu
dans la partie derrière la partie
caravane à Prague à la Coupe du monde
avec ce pion ainsi ce qui qui peut
s'offrir pendant toute la partie l'idée
c'est d'échanger un petit peu enfin un
peu le ménage au centre de pions et sur
le long terme ce pion ainsi ce qui peut
toujours devenir une faiblesse
ça ça j'aime pas du tout cette fiche
parce que je veux pas donner mon fou
contre le cavalier ça c'est hors de
question
j'ai la paire de fou comme les Noirs
ça c'est jamais de la vie
mais un jour si il partait bon bah
pourquoi pas me le faire c'est pas c'est
pas une horreur par contre le cavalier
non
ça crée la paire de fou vous n'avez pas
échanger comme ça alors
de bien solidifier un peu ce qui se
passe en A6
[Musique]
tout simplement
est-ce que vous prend un coup
franc
puis on prend d'un point et cavalier F5
waouh
c'est arrêté une rangée avant mais vu
qu'on buggé on béga
sur le chéquier en plus on a un décalage
sur la caméra
voilà c'est bien ça
me semblait mais comme ça allait trop
vite j'ai pas j'ai pas regardé la faut
prendre un geste ça a l'air pas mal ça
et ça mon téléphone
qui arrive ça a l'air hyper fort
et c'est parti il faut prendre un
justice coût brillant
et n'a qu'à qui prend sans réfléchir
[Musique]
dame
fuite OK
[Musique]
pour enlever la communication du Fou
mais je dois comprendre
écoutez je pense que c'est un petit peu
juste un par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé avant la partie ça permet de
manière un petit peu injuste avec cette
faute de souris on va dire il y a une
justice moi je parle souvent de justice
quand je suis aux échecs
tu mérites de mériter la partie ou pas
et du coup ouais je pense que c'est
justice pour Magnus justice de fait qui
brisé cette partie alors que la partie
d'avant était un petit peu injuste du
Rip alors que c'était complètement nul
pour le karma parce que c'est pas de la
faute non plus
mais plutôt la justice ouais par contre
maintenant il faut encore terminé on
voit la jauge qui monte tout là haut
mais ils font encore terminer le truc
sur cavalier prend
je dois avoir cavaler l'écran et
ça suffit ou pas
moi je me trompe direct
[Musique]
je me trompe d'Irak
du coup il va pas faire ça et si il
bouge le cavalier
je prends tous les pions en fait
ouais
c'est juste en fait
prochain coup des 6 d'un bouge d'un
progressisme c'est terminé
peut-être ça et non
ça m'a l'air juste perdu
il reste 7 minutes dans le temps
réglementaire pour ce premier set donc
après cette partie là on aura encore une
une dernière partie sur quoi prend il y
a un petit truc marrant c'est fourchette
c'est joli hein
bon tu m'as donné 35000 pièces
que je peux venir ici et encore ça en
l'air
derrière échec mais juste je pense que
juste pour H1
si je fais
tu gères comment
ça je garde toutes les menaces je pense
peut-être le plus simple
ignorer la menace de la menace de la
carte peut-être c'est le plus simple ça
je suis pas sûr que ça perde enfin c'est
compliqué mais en fait quand tu es
gagnant comme ça ce qu'il faut que tu
fasses c'est juste essayer de d'enlever
le contrôle de l'adversaire si tu
arrives à enlever le contre le jeu des
Noirs les Blancs gagnés vous voyez les
blancs des menaces concrètes ça ça si
les blancs arrivent à parer des menaces
des Noirs ça vend donc
là c'est quand même chercher quand même
les problèmes après peut-être ça marche
concrètement je mange plein de pièces tu
as vu ça marche peut-être beaucoup
pratique d'un point de vue technique on
a envie de t'empêcher tout ça de pas
rentrer dans la complications
je prends là il prend là certes donc tu
vas finir par manger une tour moi
j'aurais mangé quand même un cavalier là
et un fou donc je vais quand même
réussir à gagner du matériel mais bon le
roi est tellement faible
c'est juste perdu ça tu vois si ça a été
joué
5 voilà je bouge ma tour au moins
après
tu es perdu
il faut tenter les choses mais bon
OK et c'est gagné par Magnus
hop à partir ici
revenir ici sur la scène
tu prends ça avec les noirs et Magnus on
va lui parler son petit point
et on me dit sur le chat de YouTube que
il y a un problème de son et tout à
l'heure
je vous ai demandé s'il y a un problème
de son mais tous dit que ça ça marchait
bien et que
est-ce qu'on m'entend bien là est-ce
qu'il y a un écho est-ce qu'il y a un
problème de son
parce que j'ai l'impression que le
problème peut-être chez toi Mathieu en
fait
parce que chez moi ça marche bien on va
tout le monde dit que c'est bon
et tout à l'heure on a aussi eu un une
personne sur le chat de de YouTube qui
nous a dit qu'il y avait un problème de
son aussi peut-être que sur Youtube ça
rend moins bien je sais pas mais
c'est la deuxième personne qui
me le dit lors de ce stream et alors que
là tout le monde me dit que le son est
très très bien
donc je sais pas Mathieu peut-être que
je sais pas je sais pas quoi dire moi je
veux bien regarder mes trucs mais bon si
tout le monde dit que le son est bon
peut-être que c'est chez toi peut-être
que tes écouteurs je sais pas comment tu
écoutes je sais pas je sais pas alors
que ça c'est une française avec G5 donc
c'est marrant j'en ai parlé aujourd'hui
dans l'un de mes cours ce type de
rupture avec les noirs pour essayer de
gagner le pion central donc l'idée ici
c'est de faire G4 cavaliers prendrai 5
pas troquer le pion de l'aile contre un
pion du centre
c'est très intéressant comme position et
d'ailleurs dans la française et ben
[Musique]
souvent le roi noir reste au centre
ça ça c'est typique dans la française
c'est un jeu qui est assez difficile à
jouer cette potion de française et
d'apprendre le sang qui a été joué le
pion au 5 a été mangé je peux pas manger
des cartes à cause d'un point
et si ça a été joué
ouais c'est possible que ma pièce il y a
un petit peu de il y a un petit peu de
déco dans ma pièce moi-même je l'entends
quand je parle mais normalement le micro
il est censé gérer tout ça
si vous me dites que ça va ça va
après si je mets des écouteurs est-ce
que ça peut aider ou pas
si vous voulez je peux essayer mes
écouteurs
je vais essayer mes écouteurs vous me
dites mais je pense que ça va pas ça va
pas changer je pense mais je vais
essayer
je vais essayer des écouteurs vous me
dites si le son est mieux
est-ce que est-ce que chez vous le son
le son est mieux dites-moi
je viens de je viens de mettre mes
écouteurs je sais pas si ça peut changer
des choses ou pas dites-moi juste si ça
si ça vous aide
toujours bon mais est-ce que c'est mieux
en fait
ouais je pense pas que ça change non
plus mais c'est des fois j'en sais rien
le bruit de fonds
je suis pas un expert mais je sais que
des fois non c'est pareil bon du coup je
vais enlever ça sert à rien de toute
façon il y a rien à écouter à part le
son des pièces j'ai rien à écouter
j'essaierai tout à l'heure de voir si je
peux améliorer mon son sur twitch sur
Obs à la pause je regarderai rapidement
si je peux faire un truc mais
normalement je pense que là je suis je
suis pas mal au niveau de mes setup ah
ouais c'est important
le son est bon selon romain OK
ok donc H5 a été joué ici
et donc on défend le pion donc H5 l'idée
c'est de un jour que tu as tenir
attaquer le roi mais aussi l'idée
premièrement c'est de défendre l'option
G4 aussi une puissions assez chaude ou
le roi de mammouth va rester au centre
pendant longtemps alors des fois on
craque un petit rock ça ça peut être des
fois une option même si le roi est quand
même est quand même ouvert le 5 ça m'a
l'air suspect
m'a très suspect cette histoire de 5 à
cause de vis-à-vis qui a sur le sur le
roi généralement vous savez que
on essaie pas d'ouvrir la pollution
quand il y a le roi en face de la Tour
bon après c'est un Magnus qui fait ça je
veux pas l'expliquer la vie mais de
manière générale vous à la maison évitez
de faire sur deux choses évitez
de faire tout ça j'ai un tableau en plus
tu sais que j'ai un gros tableau
ça me dépasse ça me dépasse E5 C4 rien à
[__] bien sûr sur pion prend il y a
fou prend j'attaque là ça et c'est gain
de la dame par découverte l'idée de ces
quatre c'est que il veut ouvrir toute la
position sur le roi de Magnus bah
écoutez j'ai l'impression que Naka
celle-là et ben il peut vraiment
la gagner parce que en pratique c'est
très très dur pour Magnus qui va devoir
trouver tous les coups pour essayer pour
essayer de
[Musique]
défendre cette position c'est
extrêmement violente pour les blancs les
coups sont assez faciles à trouver parce
que c'est les blancs qui ont
l'initiative c'est les blancs qui
attaquent c'est les blancs qu'on a qu'on
la le vis-à-vis alors que les Noirs ils
ont toutes les pièces à la maison le roi
au milieu la colonne eux qui va s'ouvrir
même si la jauge dit que ça à peu près
égale je trouve qu'en pratique c'est
horrible pour les blancs quoi horrible
il y a trop de choses à calculer trop de
choses à voir alors pour les blancs
c'est tellement facile à jouer
donc
à 6
oui à 6h c'est un cookie n'aime pas
encore une fois c'est une position qui
est qui est très compliqué
et caveille ces trois
pièces il y avait ça en prise maintenant
il y a ça en prise
d'accord
ouais tu as quasiment perdu le premier
set
3 on voit maca qui est coup sur coup
bouge pas la pièce qu'on lui attaque
généralement quand vous êtes bien
surprise il faut bouger la pièce mais
lui la bouche pas s'il l'a vu ou pas il
a fait exprès
de la part de Naka je pense le 5 quand
même de malus qui était quand même très
suspect ça avait peut-être de visu pas
l'air dégueu mais n'a qu'à trouver ce C4
qui était trois qui est extrêmement
extrêmement fort et je pense que que
Garou va gagner la partie et va réussir
à égaliser dans ce dans ce match
[Musique]
avant les trois puissant et ben ça
promet encore un grand grand match donc
là cavaler ses sept roi là et je sais
pas comment on continue mais ça a l'air
ça a l'air d'être un cauchemar quand
même pour les blancs pas pour les Noirs
pardon le roi qui se balade sur le
chéquier il y a une pièce de plus qu'un
pour les Noirs donc il faut encore finir
coup manquer c'était ouais apparemment
il y avait un gain alors le gars je peux
vous le dire cavalier prend c'est 6
et ça
c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu quand même
manger là et manger là il fallait chaque
manger la tour
c'est vrai que c'était quand même pas
très dur à voir donc été joué et du coup
il y a plus de fourchette sur échec roi
là
c'est chaud mais Magnus on a vu une
grosse partie de lui c'était dommage
contre qui c'était contre firou le matin
c'était dans un autre tournoi on avait
vu le match du Champions contre firou je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez il y
avait une partie où le roi de Magnus a
fait le tour de l'échiquier plusieurs
fois et il a terminé victorieux de la
partie c'était juste monstrueux donc en
défense Magnus il est quand même très
très fort
mais en pratique c'est juste incroyable
quoi t'es cloué de partout tu peux pas
bouger d'un processus je sais pas j'ai
même pas vu que c'était possible j'ai
pas vu que c'était un coup possible d'un
processus apparemment tu prends là c'est
perdu là il y a toujours fait partout
c'est c'est juste perdu c'est terminé
mais bon ok
hyper complexe hyper complexe il faut
baisser cela ben j'ai découvert là
et maintenant vous allez voir plein de
coups plein de mauvais coups d'affilée
c'est normal la position elle est
complètement injouable il y a des
cavaliers qui peut bouger un peu de
partout pour
faire la découverte et pour un humain
cette position c'est tellement difficile
pour pouvoir sortir avec le roi en G7 le
fou qui bloquait la case du roi la
monstrueux
même pas il bouge la tour rouge
que 40 secondes contre 25
ouais c'est chaud c'est chaud
comment est-ce qu'on continue
d'apprendre les quatre qui va arriver
des trois tours
je ne j'ai du mal à suivre j'ai du mal à
suivre
dans quelle horreur cette partie
en tournoi
les deux jours en PLS avec avec 15
secondes chacun c'est c'est extrêmement
dur comme position il y a plein
d'erreurs mais c'est normal c'est normal
qui est plein d'erreurs la position
humainement gardé
le bordel que c'est quoi dame là à la
logique quand même
[Musique]
ou F4
c'est quoi
j'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi
tours
arnaquer sur le fil et là c'est juste
perdu maintenant
c'est perdu on va manger un F6 c'est une
découverte aussi qui était possible
c'est complètement terminé
les parties franchement les joueurs nous
nous offre un très très gros spectacle
apparemment c'était gagnant ici
on peut voir cavalier
ce qui passe de gagnant à perdant en un
coup apparemment fallait jouer avec 6
et une fois que je bouge le fou je peux
même pas bouger le four en t'en prends
un F3
après c'est compliqué vous voyez Anaïs
et la pollution c'est c'est ouf moi
c'est pareil j'ai rien compris à la
partie et encore là j'avais mon ordi
parce que parce que je voulais essayer
de vous offrir un minimum de
commentaires mais juste trop dur
les joueurs sont beaucoup trop forts et
même pour les joueurs c'est un cauchemar
si vous regardez un petit peu est-ce que
je peux vous montrer là je sais pas si
on a accès aux
ouais voilà quand vous voyez que que
Magnus avec les noirs a fait 75% de
précision c'est que vraiment il a la
partie est difficile parce que
généralement même si ça emblés les
joueurs ils font 95-90 tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps et là ils sont à 75% de précisant
tous les deux
ça monte bien que c'était une
catastrophe niveau des coûts quand on
regarde la feuille de partie là on voit
que il y a eu plein de coups en rouge de
partout des deux côtés c'est c'est hyper
difficile voilà donc on fait une petite
pause avant le deuxième set donc je vais
quand même vous rajouter le petit point
de la cave bien mérité quatrième point
et on revient dans un instant pour le
deuxième set vous aurez une heure de
trois plus une et pendant ce temps là je
vais voir si je peux réparer ces petits
problèmes déco je sais pas si c'est
possible mais je vais aller voir si
enfin ce que je peux faire en tout cas
je vous dis à tout de suite
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analysez avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts
et même vos personnalités préférées du
monde des échecs émoticônes et les
emojis disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts spéciales reste sur les chéquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
les joueurs ne sont toujours parvenus
mais je voulais voir un petit peu de
temps je sais pas si
ça vous intéresse mais cette partie
larveur rapidement voir ce qui s'est
passé parce que j'ai littéralement à
rien compris du tout ce qui s'est passé
pour cette partie on peut prendre ça
trois minutes avant que les gens
reprennent
vous me direz sur le chat sur Youtube si
le son s'est améliorer que quelques
petits trucs mais je sais pas si ça va
changer des choses
donc le 5 était un mauvais coup bon on
peut le deviner parce que on met la on
ouvre la position quand on a le droit en
face de la Tour c'est clair que
que ça a l'air pas bon mais après bon
pourquoi pas je veux dire il faut encore
trouver la fuite ici
[Musique]
c'est hyper dur
chez toujours bien rangé la chambre
robinsight toujours comme ça donc c'est
le coup le coup hyper bon en tout cas le
coup brillant de la part de la carte on
laisse le cavalier en prise et bien sûr
surprise
et je gagne la dame
donc sur ces quatre il y a eu A6 pour
forcer un petit peu des prises de saison
et des échanges et ici n'a qu'à s'en
fout il a fait quand même qu'elle avait
cette droite qui a un coup qui est très
très bon
et donc sur plus on prend il y a le
cavaler prendre S5 dame G6 et là ici le
gain manqué de la part de Naka avec
avalé français 6 suite qu'elle va
laisser cette quitter qui était fort
mais après d'un processus on prend et
c'est pas facile de se rendre compte que
la position allait être complètement
gagnante en tout cas quand on fait un
blitz comme ça on peut rapidement passer
à côté
de ça quoi
et du coup il a joué à la place et prend
les cinq tombes à 8 donc il y a plus de
fourchette
échec voilà archi gagnant apparemment ça
ne l'est pas F5 c'est le seul coup pour
ne pas perdre mais bon c'est hyper dur
quoi pourquoi pas je ne sais pas
c'est hyper dur à calculer il y a des
choses de partout juste pas bouger mes
pièces
c'est le meilleur coup le roi s'échappe
et je prends comme ça je prends le
dessus
et bon bah ça joue ça joue c'est
compliqué
c'est un repris on va revenir sur le
direct mais bon
partie parler de malade mentaux
trop trop dur
[Musique]
comment Magnus va jouer ici souvent on
peut manger en 4 on peut aussi faire
dame pour
[Musique]
pour
obtenir le contrôle de
choix aussi est un coup mais je sais pas
si je dis des bêtises mais pas du tout
un expert à ces positions je ne joue pas
du tout peut-être avec les Blancs et ni
ça avec les avec les Noirs non plus
mais j'avais déjà vu un dame FK quelque
part je sais pas si c'était ici
les pièces sont échangées donc n'a qu'à
qui
c'est assez antipollutionnel mais
ça le mérite d'être actif et d'attaquer
aussi le pion des 4 ici et surtout en D1
comment ça va se jouer
comment est-ce qu'on joue ces soins ou
simples comme tourner
[Musique]
on va le savoir
on va le savoir de suite
parce que j'ai l'impression quand même
que la pollution noire elle a un poil
bizarre que la B3 du coup ah je peux
aussi manger des 7 et quelques
noirs cette position j'aime bien le
blanc c'est un jeu assez solide quand
même j'ai le centre car il est mal placé
ici depuis un F4 donne la case de 4 pour
une pièce la pression quand même que ça
se passe bien pour pas mal de cette
position mais bon quand je vois que Naka
à 255
[Musique]
ça fait peur on se dit que Naka est plus
ou moins encore danser dans sa prépa le
son est meilleur Mathieu ok j'ai fait
j'ai fait enlever le bruit de fond
mais du coup
en tant que ça aille mieux chez toi
donc du coup Kamel le 4 ma la logique E3
a été joué ou attention
à F3
F3 et ce matin
j'arrive pas à comprendre
ça me fait peur
d'apprendre à parler français alors je
regarde les streams français
bah écoute c'est cool c'est bien il faut
parler français tu parles quelle langue
tu parles quelle langue de quel pays
divorce forever
[Musique]
je parle pas mal de langues mais
l'allemand c'est pas du tout dans les
langues que je parle alors
malheureusement je pourrai pas
communiquer avec toi je suis désolé
tout rêve 4 très joli hein pression sur
le champ ici attaque H4 et bien sûr on
profite du clouage j'ai pas aimé le F3
non plus hein tout à l'heure enfin le
coup au troisième blanc j'ai pas du tout
aimé
[Musique]
je suis anti Londres en fait il y a il y
a plein de de même etc Un sur Londres
comme quoi Londres c'est une ouverture
un petit peu pleutre etc
moi j'ai rien contre Londres en général
mais c'est vrai que c'est une ouverture
c'est vrai
[Musique]
qui est un peu schématique
qui peut être des fois un peu ennuyeuse
en tout cas moi actif un genre qui aime
bien attaquer et le Londres je peux vous
dire que je jouerai je jouerai jamais ça
toute ma vie
et comment est-ce qu'on continue ça
lardure quand les blancs j'aime pas la
pollution blanche mais je sais pas
comment on continue avec les noirs
juste un coup de
la position
[Musique]
après à ce qu'il y a un truc concret
si je prends H4 et ben je perds F3
ça je peux pas enfin peut-être que je
peux
pas trop envie de donner 3 c'est
vraiment l'épine la position
[Musique]
je pars Naka et Naka qui est très
content de ce coup on a vu la caméra
il observe Magnus qui est sa carte il
observe supportable ça y est je crois
que c'est le moment de cacher la caméra
de Maka
si je reviens
ah ça marche 5 maintenant
peut-être ou la chose qui remonte tout
là haut
je comptais faire ça et chaque ah
peut-être il y a pas de maths OK
bon j'ai la bonne idée mais je dois
mettre tromper peut-être dame G4 voilà
un truc comme ça
[Musique]
a été joué
d'un projet 3 waouh
ça c'est ça c'est du coup ça c'est
monstrueux et la Naka qui se redresse
incroyable scorpion prend échec
échec et ça va être mat ouais c'est joli
c'est extrêmement joli monstrueux
monstrueux la prédit on va vouloir
donner d'ailleurs c'est avec ma news a
gagné
le premier set je suis désolé j'ai
complètement oublié ah ouais il est fier
et du coup
Naka qui vient de gagner sa deuxième
partie d'affilée et qui revient au score
à 5 5 maintenant dans ce match
alors je vais payer les dettes
donc l'après midi il y avait il y a eu
54 pour Magnus donc Magnus gagnant du
premier va vous distribuer les points
distribuer les points donc c'est Magnus
qui a remporté
hop et si vous voulez on se fait le même
petit Paris
en ce même Paris si vous voulez mais
avec le Blitz
que dites-vous
qu'est-ce que vous en dites
5 minutes pour voter
5 minutes pour voter ouais c'était hyper
beau hein en vrai des fois des fois il
est insupportable Naka
mais en vrai la sénéité parti il est
quand même ultra jolie
là il mérite d'être insupportable
alors je vous laisse voter si vous
voulez voter sur le sur le score quand
sur le gagnant du du 7 donc là on voit
les gens qui commencent à faire all-in
sur Naka Naka qui mène un zéro quand
même dans ce dans ce
dans ce set mène 1-0 il est à deux
parties d'affilée gagné
parce qu'on a commencé avec gazon 4000
au début et là ça fait ça fait 5
résultats
[Musique]
c'est Magnus
après je peux voir si je peux ajuster
mais
s'il va d'un côté ou de l'autre
malheureusement je peux pas y faire
grand chose je peux pas jeter un peu
plus si vous voulez mais
je voulais juste mais bon après quand il
partira vers la gauche je le remettrai à
droite
du coup je suis désolé robinside ouais
j'ai pas fait le changement de de
scène du coup je remette encore une fois
ma tenue à gauche
je vais je vais vous remettre ma news à
gauche
en fait j'ai une scène quand mamie elle
est blanche et une scène quand elle a
les noirs
du coup à chaque fois
pardon à chaque partie il faut que
il faut que je vous que je change de
chaîne
Magnus a gagné le 5 + 1 et maintenant on
parle de 3 + 1 10 fois
on est en 3 + 1 pour les Paris il nous
reste encore environ 3 minutes parier si
on favoris dans ce 7 à savoir prendre le
bon et oublier de mauvais chez l'esprit
humain
[Musique]
ok alors
j'aime bien les blancs de travail il y a
un E5 qui peut être possible
comment est-ce que je vois de la
pression ici F4 ça peut être intéressant
avec F5 éventuellement
mais F4 ça bloque le fou faut acheter
j'aime bien et F4 maintenant c'est plus
de sens
plus de sens comme ça me laisse E5 ou
bouge et Matt
E5 F5 et là je menace d'ailleurs très
très jolie non je me lasse pas encore
mais je menace presque demander
4 bon en tout cas il y a de la taxi dans
l'air
et est-ce que le 5 serait pas le seul
coup
je peux faire j'ai 6 ans
pas la qualité je sais bien mais bon
mais bon j'aime pas les blancs
je trouve que la position est
extrêmement difficile il y a une grosse
attaque sur le sur le roi et en plus
avec 45 secondes à la pendule c'est
très très difficile
après un cas je pense qu'il est encore
plus fort
[Musique]
quand il stream
je pense que Naka en fait quand il quand
il a son public derrière lui comme ça et
qui peut parler etc j'ai l'impression
que c'est là les rangs hyper fort il
prend force de son chat de ses fans qui
ne regardent et là bien sûr qui ne
regarde mais il est pas en string donc
du coup
c'est différent mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il est encore plus fort quand il peut
streamer en fait
[Musique]
mais en fait il y a des gens comme ça il
y a des gens que streamer c'est
difficile parce que tu arrives pas à
parler et en même temps être concentré
sur tes parties etc etc je peux
comprendre mais il y a des gens qui ont
besoin de ça et justement ça leur donne
de la force de stream il se sentent plus
important et
booster par par tout ça et je pense que
c'est un peu le cas de le cas de
Magnus pendant des carreaux
tours 5 secondes pour Magnus Magnus qui
pourrait peut-être perdre sa troisième
partie d'affilée ce serait incroyable
ce serait incroyable
[Musique]
là ça pourrait faire un petit thé un peu
Magnus
qui menait quand même dans ce match de
deux points qui peut se retrouver à être
à -1 à peu près trois parties d'affilée
ça le crabe
qui va arriver intermédiaire il y a ça
en l'air
ça a été abandon
incroyable trois parties d'un filet 3
victoires d'affilée pour pour Naka et
qui reste bloqué à 5 points
car ça ne s'y reste complètement bloqué
à 5 points et des points de Naka qui
font que de monter on a 6,5 pour le
joueur américain
c'est ça qu'on a 2-0 dans cette phase de
Blitz et encore 46 minutes et encore il
y a encore beaucoup beaucoup de parties
pas mal de choses qui peuvent se passer
mais il faut rester concentré
ça Magnus il est quand même concentré
vous voyez malgré tout il sait qu'il y a
que un point d'écart et que même si
parfois partie de la filet il est encore
dans le match
mais c'est chaud
dans des pollutions où il avait vraiment
des choses et c'est vrai que on a
l'impression que là dans la partie en
tout cas Naka il joue hyper bien et il
arrive à mater Magnus alors que dans le
match le maximum on trouve Magnus et ben
on voit que Maxime avait un peu
l'ascendant dans ce match en tout cas au
niveau des parties
il a il a fait de beaux spectacles et il
méritait peut-être plus que que ça bon
il a perdu le match donc mais je pense
qu'il méritait franchement de gagner ce
match il a montré de très bonne qualité
et très belle partie
[Musique]
alors que la sac dans ce match là
Magnus il est
un niveau on vient un petit peu décevant
par rapport à ce qu'on a l'habitude de
voir
donc là on joue contre
contre les fous j'en ai fermé donc la
magie se dit que la paire de fou des
Noirs va être mauvaise et c'est pour ça
qu'il a je sais cette position vous
pouvez imaginer un jour en cavalier B3
cavalier à 5 pour aller placer ce cahier
là-haut je suis pas sûr que ça soit bien
en fait là maintenant je suis pas
d'accord avec ce que je viens de dire
tellement nul en B7 pas forcément envie
d'aller les changer de suite on prise 4
en dessin qui est intéressant pour
mettre un cavalier en E3 sur le long
terme pour jumper en dessin que ça peut
être intéressant
son rippage
pas si grave mais maintenant que tu
perdres tu peux te dire
il y a eu des assez des choses
effectivement
mais
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai que ouais son ripage
s'en rippage c'est ce qui a ouvert le
score ça se fait au vers le score à maca
et c'est ce qui a motivé la caméra qui
était un peu fondu trop qui arrive pas à
en gagner une seule après cinq parties
la caméra avait marqué 0.1
et c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'après après après avoir
gagné cette partie avec faute de souris
pas il s'est réveillé ça l'a réveillé en
fait et maintenant il joue hyper bien il
a enclenché la machine d'accord là il
mène au score
mais
[Musique]
donc ça a été joué attention le pion
c'est 3 qui est en prise est-ce qu'on
fait Dame des trois on laisse la place
en cavalier futur en dessin est-ce qu'on
joue tout à trois pour doubler sur la
Colonna ce qu'il a fait là trois tours
un jour je pourrais peut-être passer en
mais je pense qu'un plan général bouger
la dame à mettre un cavalier je sais pas
lequel en dessin
[Musique]
et dominer les mauvaises pièces noires
car elle débite j'aime bien ce que tu
aimes bien
mais il y a cavalier 6 cavalier F4 qui
va être
probablement jouer mais je ferai G3 du
coup genre ça Cavalaire ici j'ai trois
pour pêcher qui avait des F4
et essayer de tourner qu'avec un E3 ça
la partie mais faire ce plan là avec le
cavalier sur la case de la dame
c'est ce que j'aimerais faire la G3
malheureusement
parce que tu peux
la repas généralement
est-ce que c'est vraiment gênant il a
toléré il le laisse mais j'imagine que
sur cavalier F4 il se dit Madame des
deux et j'ai trois et cavalier 5 ok
généralement ici essayez de mettre vos
pièces
sur la couleur de vos fous et si vous en
avez pas vous allez sur la couleur
inverse du coup l'adversaire donc là il
a un fou de case noir donc généralement
il faut avoir un jeu surcasse blanche un
jour sur la couleur inverse regardez G3
rois G2 tourner et vraiment essayer de
se mettre sur la couleur inverse du coup
de l'adversaire
alors demande sur Youtube si
la réglementation pour pour le jeu
anti-triche oui
déjà les les organes les arbitres du
coup voit l'écran
l'écran enfin les écrans des joueurs il
y a partage leur écran et partage tout
il y a aussi des caméras qui sont
derrière eux ils filment toute la pièce
et puis en plus les parties enfin les
vidéos
zoom sont sont enregistrées et s'il y a
une plainte ou quoi que ce soit ils
pourront plus tard revisionner tout ça
et revoir un peu si vraiment et suspecte
pas que ce soit etc
après voilà en général les joueurs sont
très connus il y a pas de triche entre
eux
les joueurs voilà ils sont pas besoin de
ça enfin juste donc il y a pas de
problème mais ça c'est les les règles un
petit peu anti-triche
mais pour un tournoi avec on va dire
prestige
il pourrait y avoir il y a toujours vous
savez il y a toujours des choses comme
ça après dans tous les sports mais dans
ce genre de tournoi là avec avec la
meilleure du monde
vous verrez pas Magnus quoi
ça c'est pas
dire Magnus qui est plus fort que Sophie
un jour où c'est 5 tourbé 4 il a pas le
temps B4
tour des deux d'abord et il bloque là
qui
va tomber sur le long terme comme
attention à ce point
je pense qu'il aime les noirs qui
peuvent baisser de la jouer un peu à
maintenant non maintenant j'aime plus
les noirs
qui est quasiment passé mais bon ça a
pas gagné ça a pas gagné je pense pour
les blancs
j'imagine pas trop parce que le roi est
coupé vous voyez comme le roi est coupé
et ben malheureusement je peux pas
progresser beaucoup
ça va répéter
ça va faire nul et ça a fait nul ah non
pas sur la prochaine partie on va
rajouter le demi point au deux joueurs
et du coup maca qui mène toujours d'un
demi point dans ce match
qui est C4 était toujours par maca alors
tout à l'heure il a joué un plan d'Acca
avec un cavalier des deux et un tour
simple pour je C4 donc je pense qu'il
est préparé dans ce match
des idées à base de ces quatre de
manière générale dans les dans
l'espagnol
oui voilà il y a environ
[Musique]
alors je sais pas si on l'a dans le chat
ça a été demandé mais le match dure
trois heures donc il y a 1h30 ça écrit
sur en tout bon là c'est écrit 1h30 de 5
+ 1 1h20 + 1 et une demi-heure de 1 + 1
ça fait 3 heures après plus les pauses
ça fera environ une demi-heure de pause
cumulée donc on a environ à 3h30 de jeu
ça commence à le match commence à 20h je
pense que 23h30 ce sera terminé et on
rentre à la maison
des 4 a été joué
attention la position qui s'ouvre alors
que le noir on la part de fou toujours
un peu compliqué ces décisions à prendre
manger parfois si ça peut être une idée
aussi prise et c'est simple qui peut
être aussi une idée d'ailleurs
et quand je fais des 5 je vois que tu
comprends la chose
qui avance et du coup le pion qui de
base peut être arriéré voyez sur la
colonne C qui pouvait être vraiment un
prix comme target mais après c'est
simple devient à passer mais veut dire
il est plus du tout en danger et surtout
on prend maintenant c'est toi qui a un
problème son pion en 4
la paire de fou qui va s'activer les
noirs sont pas mal du tout j'ai
l'impression comment ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
il y a eu des quatre ici réfléchit
Magnus
aussi ouais pour essayer de sortir mon
fou ici je pense
que donc C6
t'inquiète pas Billy moi non plus je
comprends pas tout non plus les parties
qui font elles sont tellement
compliquées et ça va tellement vite en
plus que c'est difficile de commenter
vraiment
on va dire bien de manière
écheciennement parlant c'est très dur ça
va trop vite en fait je peux pas vous
expliquer vraiment
l'enjeu des positions etc mais on essaie
on essaie de faire au mieux j'arrive pas
à parler les gars je suis fatigué
j'arrive plus à parler
mais c'est pas évident de parler d'échec
quand c'est du Blitz et que ça va aussi
vite
tu vas me prendre des cinq c'est pas le
problème
c'est une bonne question je pense qu'il
y avait une fourchette qui prenait
derrière peut-être
il est pas défendable je peux me faire
tourner 8 c'est là où celle-là moi
j'aime bien faut F6
que ça
ça active les pièces B4 avec les jouets
[Musique]
un petit peu on peut voir alors pour C8
qui peut arriver attention aux
fourchette
attention aux fourchettes
parce que ça avait l'air bien quand même
possible
je prends la tour qui va se changer et
l'idée c'est que sur ça peut-être que
j'ai ça j'ai le temps de faire pour pour
C8
je sais pas si possible mais là
j'aimerais bien avoir le contrôle
cavaler ici jouer
ici à 36
il faut éviter ce qui va arriver c'est
ça
[Musique]
très créatif regardez si bouge de fou il
mange B2 c'est un pion passé avec la
paire de fou qui va tout défendre ça
peut totalement dame ça peut être ça
peut être très très très très
compliqué pour un cas
même tour des deux fous des quatre
je mange B2
attaquez-vous ça peut être très dur pour
défendre chez les Blancs
parce que tout ravi de 5 coups
te dire ok change les pièces tu auras
envie de te reprendre cavalier prend
mais deux je pourrai pas le prendre
maintenant sur un tourbillon
[Musique]
et même là regarde en fait juste pour
qu'on comprenne à quel point ça peut
être intéressant
et quand tu bouges bah je reviens et je
fais ça ça c'est intéressant ce qu'il a
fait
4 waouh
regardez un tour sur le foot tellement
il voulait pas avoir chaud
pour la
et là c'est extrêmement compliqué je
défonce le plus en tour des cadres
ok ça a l'air assez égal cette position
et vous voyez le coup tu reprends ici ça
montre vraiment la compréhension de Naka
il a compris que que le plan de maintenu
ça va être le premier d'eux était
extrêmement puissant et c'est pas pris
la tête il a vu de sacrifier la qualité
pour pas être ennuyé avec le contre le
jeu et il se dit que au moins en faisant
ça il va sécuriser la nul
là on a une position assez égale un pion
quand même ici est-ce que c'est grave ce
qui va me faire il peut pas défendre
depuis un tour de 5
quels
attention que la Magnus peut
perdre encore une deuxième partie
d'affilée ce serait ce serait dur
qui pourrait être mené deux points
[Musique]
je pense qu'il va devoir faire
et sur B7 quasiment plus bouger le droit
vous savez qu'il y a un piège on pourra
le voir après c'est jouer
bon on va voir si un jour il fait
baisser
du coup
F7 perd
c'est ça et surtout reprends j'enfile
c'est un piège qui est très connu
bon alors niveau ça marche pas ils vont
pas se faire piéger comme ça
mais le roi veut pas bouger si le roi
bouge il y aura échec et dames
et le Roi peut faire que roi H7
en fait mon roi il est complètement
[Musique]
buggé ici
et en plus la tour tu as toujours
revenir après en bien obligé
empêcher chaque et d'arbre
il attend
ici abandon si tu réchauffer
il y avait toujours tout échec et dame
la grosse technique de macaren mais à ce
niveau là c'est gagné facile
incroyable Naka qui prend vraiment le
large avec deux points
dans ce match
trois et demi à 0 et demi
en
blitz écouter pour ceux qui ont parlé
surnaka dans ce set et bien vous êtes
pas mal là maintenant d'un cas qui joue
la berlinoise d'un cas qui qui est c'est
vraiment de très solide et aussi jouer
des positions on va dire un petit peu
longue
cette position de berlinoise sont très
solides c'était final assez lentes et au
vu de plus de en point de la carte je
pense que c'est c'est une bonne idée de
ce genre de choses parce que tu peux
perdre la partie mais si tu la perds tu
peux la perdre en beaucoup beaucoup de
temps avec ses positions
qui peuvent durer longtemps et Naka il
aime beaucoup je le Time dans ses dans
ces
porter
ces tournois
il a une tête de fatigué ici
tu as du mal à
jouer il a bien commencé au début
c'était vraiment pas mal et là ça fait
quelques parties là qu'il arrive plus
Magnus il est à quasiment quatre
défaites d'affilée je crois
on l'a vu regardez il a une non c'était
pas ça il a une deux trois quatre ouais
il s'est pris quatre et demi à 0,5
c'est c'est
dur là il faut se réveiller il faut se
réveiller chez Magnus parce que là il a
moins deux ce qui est pas encore trop
loin ça reste encore complètement
jouable c'est pas grand chose de points
mais bon il y en a plus de au début
maintenant il a moins de c'est un très
gros match en tout cas
les gens de la trompe de Magnus Nakam vn
ne triche pas car il serait bon après il
y en a qui peuvent toujours le faire
mais bon en fait moi je pense que quand
tu aimes vraiment le jeu d'échec juste
après tricher c'est un truc
déjà un peu son professionnel
[Musique]
etc bon juste à ce niveau là t'as pas le
droit de tricher juste à trois perles en
plus quoi tu as trop à perdre
mais en plus de ça du fait d'avoir trop
à perdre et ben les joueurs se
respectent déjà entre eux et en plus le
jeu donc d'ailleurs ça c'est bien c'est
cool je pense que toutes ces cadences là
bon bien sûr il y a plein de mesures en
Dietrich mais les joueurs savent les
joueurs se respectent entre eux et
franchement
c'est parmi pour les baelo ben
en fait c'est pas permis mais c'est vrai
que que tu verras plus de triche je
pense c'est les c'est les joueurs de
baelo
parce qu'en fait ces joueurs là souvent
bah ils s'en foutent parce qu'il y a pas
le même intérêt qui aurait un joueur qui
habite sa carrière à faire ce qu'il a
fait etc
ça c'est clair c'est leur vie
[Musique]
c'est la vie si demain tu vois que ma
nounou c'est ma triche
du monde ou pas tu as triché quoi c'est
terminé
[Musique]
en fait c'est comme ça
je crois que Magnus il préfère ne pas
gagner
ce tournoi là et juste normal quoi donc
dans tous les sports c'est pareil dans
tous les sports
mais l'intérêt de triche dans les bases
c'est de se gonfler un petit peu son élo
et de et de gonfler aussi son ego
regarde j'ai tendez l'eau je suis fort
mais en fait non tu sais que c'est pas
vrai
que tu l'as pas obtenu normalement ton
bref
[Musique]
encore s'il y avait de l'argent dans les
événements j'aime pas ça mais je
pourrais comprendre tu triches mais non
mais généralement les gens ils trichent
juste pour gonfler leur vélo donc vous
voyez vraiment l'utilité quoi
est possible ici
on se rouage
à la maison
de garder un peu
parce que
de case sur la colonne h et la partie
reste
Magnus avec les Blancs Magnus qui doit
gagner la partie pour essayer de revenir
un peu dans ce match
[Musique]
F4 aussi c'est un coup mais F4 à te
reprendre à 5 ah c'est la même c'est la
même à la Dino la tour est toujours
enfermée et 4 pas mal
pas mal aussi je crois que tous nos
coups sont bons
4 F4 R4 donc tous nos coups sont bons
décision là plus de 20 secondes
44 ça fait
trop de temps là
[Musique]
et en fait là il s'est encore fait
arnaquer bon c'est pas terminé encore du
tout parce que s'il mange là je rentre
le fou et je vais essayer de pousser le
pion et si il mange ici comme c'est la
partie il va défendre il va pousser le
pion F ça reste compliqué
j'aime bien je trouve ça fort si je
pousse perd ses deux à contrejection ici
donc on décide il prend F2
[Musique]
il sait qu'il va pas la gagner
et ouais il prend trop de risques qu'il
a mal au temps Magnus est prêt à faire
nul pour pour sauver un peu sa peau
cette partie
cavalier pas mal il y a un problème sur
le sur le fou ici
[Musique]
un problème est marqué Armageddon en
haut mais c'est pas vrai là juste à la
fin je pense cette partie va y avoir une
pause la pause de la moitié la moitié du
attention il y a presque
craquage mais je crois que ça va quand
même faire nul le pion c'est 4 il pourra
pas être défendu et ça a fallu quand
même hein
pour le coup c'est assez facile à tenir
après encore des pions qui peuvent des
fois cacher des cases pour le roi mais
bon je vois pas du tout comment ça peut
parce que même pas sortir
et même c'est même les noirs qui peuvent
même la gagner peut-être regardez
le pion qui avance
il fait complètement n'importe quoi
Magnus il est fatigué de perdre une
finale complètement impermable c'est
c'est dur c'est dur là il faut se
réveiller à Magnus ça fait quand même 5
parties d'affilée quasiment qui perd et
le 7 à 4,5
fait très très mal là pour pour Magnus
cette moitié de de cette alors j'ai pas
compris non plus un Robinson ce qui
s'est passé ici il a mangé la pièce mais
avec tous les pions enfin les pions qui
va perdre et ben ça reste très difficile
mais tour de 4 il vient couper le roi
noir en noir et blanc et il veut pousser
le fiancé mais ici
sachant que le roi est coupé c'est pas
si évident pour moi
et après ça sur le coup cet orage c'est
quoi
pas évident en fait
qui va se refaire on le sait je voulais
cette seconde petite pause et on revient
dans 5 minutes le temps pour Magnus de
reprendre un peu ses esprits et puis on
est de retour de suite je vous dis à
tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title
tuesday.com/aventem tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats des
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis de retour
avec un parti qui n'ont pas encore
repris du tout moi qui fait des mini
pause que j'ai peur que les joueurs
commencent sans moi je suis toujours en
avance donc pour répondre au chat il
reste pas que le Bullet là on est on est
il nous reste la deuxième moitié du 3 +
1 donc en haut à gauche vous avez marqué
Armageddon normalement c'était pas ça
malheureusement c'est pas moi qui qui
gère et du coup je crois qu'il reste
environ une demi-heure de temps dans les
3 + 1 et ensuite on aura on aura le
Bullet en une plus une voilà
donc
les joueurs qui arrivent n'a qu'à qui
est installé
et carcène qui va arriver dans quelques
instants qui est il y a 5 défaites
d'affilée et une nulle au milieu on met
5 défaites d'affilée
Magnus qui menait de deux points ce
match et après 5 parties d'affilée 8h de
Naka d'affilée c'est hyper difficile
hyper difficile il faut qu'il se
réveille il est encore il est encore là
il est encore là et et si il gagne la
prochaine partie je pense qu'il est
vraiment moyen de revenir il y a encore
une demi-heure deux trois plus simples
et une demi-heure de de Bullet donc
franchement il y a de quoi il y a de
quoi revenir dans ce match Magnus
trois points c'est beaucoup mais à la
fois c'est pas beaucoup
c'est possible s'il retrouve s'il
retrouve son jeu je pense qu'il y a un
bon moyen de faire quelque chose les
points commencent à marche tout
simplement
tout simplement dès que tu marques dès
qu'il y a une particularité
donc Magnus qui a gagné 5 parties et
demi et Nakamura qui a gagné 8 parties
et demi c'est comme ça elle est partie
qui vont reprendre les joueurs qui sont
à reprendre il reste environ une
demi-heure donc là je sais pas vraiment
au niveau de du timer je sais pas ce qui
est donné je le vois l'Armageddon il y a
marqué un magret dedans mais normalement
il y a le il y a le
oui mais c'est pas vrai là en fait c'est
un bug je pense de James comme sushiban
parce que normalement ici c'est un timer
qui est posé
et on est encore dans les phases de 7
donc normalement
voilà c'est quoi le score qui a écrit 00
le score y a marqué à côté de chaque
personne de nombre de points qu'il y a
et en dessous
Jacques Dubois c'est pas marqué 0-0 du
tout tu as le score qui écrit après
partout tu le vois sur plusieurs
endroits sur le sur le tableau de stream
donc normalement tu rates pas
normalement voir le score il est écrit
[Musique]
mais là dans ce sac en 3 + 1 c'est 4,5
pour Naka et c'est
ultra chaud donc une petite
avec
Jessie OK
[Musique]
on sort les pièces car je crois qu'il
empêche
qui doit absolument savoir faire un
Magnus qui est hyper 5 parties d'affilée
c'est ouf à ce niveau là
mais voyez chaque joueur un peu avoir
des fois des baisses de régime et peut
faire un mauvais manage ou ou juste
battre en forme quoi mais en tout cas
Magnus peut encore revenir il faut qu'il
y croit
moi j'ai confiance franchement
je pense qu'il peut franchement revenir
dans ce match Magnus moi ça va donner en
favori en tout cas dans ce début de
match je pense enfin je le voyais en
tout cas comme favoris et de joueurs
sont extrêmement forts
du circuit et le timer qui s'est remis à
jour mais qui reste 20 minutes dans ce
timer pour ce 7 donc bien sûr je pense
que quatre et demi 0h30 Magnus ne pourra
pas forcément revenir ça fait quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de points à faire en
si peu de temps donc je pense que le 7
va être pour un aka mais le 7 n'a pas de
valeur encore une fois
est-ce que j'arrive à comprendre ce qui
se passe j'ai l'impression
que sur pion il veut Caval il y a trois
et cavaliers
pour manger là
où est-ce qu'il veut juste manger la
direct et dit je m'en fous
de la part de Naka
[Musique]
n'hésite pas à simplifier la pièce
alors qu'il aimait les trois points ça
c'est ouf ça c'est ouf
donc d'un point H3
qui peut arriver
et du cavalier F4 qui peut aussi arriver
du mal à calculer peut-être ça ça et sur
ça il y a au moins cavalier de
pour chatte au moins ça
en tout cas ça fait réfléchir un accord
de trouver une solution
très très vite
il y a deux minutes 18 pour le pour
Magnus 40 secondes pour un cas
génial pour pour le match
Manu ce serait plus qu'à moins 2 dans ce
match il y a vraiment de quoi se refaire
il y a clairement de quoi se faire
fou le sang qui était loin apparemment
c'est pas un coup que la jauge aime
c'est pas du tout un coup que la jauge
aime
là je vois un truc comme ça ouais je
pensais à sac là attaque là
mais est-ce que je veux vraiment manger
la tour je suis pas sûr je pense qu'il
va garder les pièces cavalage 5 où
j'aime bien menacer
c'est la partie qui avait les F4 dame G2
car à l'étranger 3 aussi est une est une
menace
ça a l'air complètement gagnant pour
Magnus cette partie et la qui fait la
gueule il fait la gueule
d'un F5 car elle est le 4
même comme ça les gens arrivent à
trouver des complications c'est juste
ouf car elle est plonger 3 sans qu'elle
va les prendre et d'apprendre
si on prend
faut voir tous les quatre qui peut
arriver en tout cas la partie
quand même l'air pas génial pour pour
Naka qui a plus que 13 secondes à la
pendule
pas c'est un moyen de punir à votre
cavaler prendre si vous prendrez bien
ça semble être
mais il faut trouver un truc concret en
défense il est quand même extrêmement
fort ah si ça a été joué
[Musique]
du mal au moral au Magnus il prend la
tour derrière
[Musique]
je pense qu'il n'y a absolument rien à
faire F5 à la fraise
quand tu bouges de cavalier chaque et
je crois que c'est juste perdu non
[Musique]
pas d'échec
c'est juste horrible dans ces trois
hop hop hop
et ici peut-être tourner 6 tours D8 pour
Descartes
pour les deux tours c'est complètement
gagnant mais mais en fait voilà Naka il
va essayer de faire durer la partie
parce que il mène au score de 3 points
et du coup tu peux aussi jouer contre la
montre en tout cas c'est ce qui va
essayer de faire juste pour gagner un
petit peu de temps pour que Magnus est
moins de temps pour pour se refaire
[Musique]
c'est juste et c'est gagné abandon de la
part de Naka Emmaüs qui revient
qui revient à -2 j'ai fait une une
erreur de scène excusez moi Magnus qui
est blanc dans la prochaine partie ça
fait du bien de rajouter un point à
Magnus ça faisait longtemps que j'ai pas
rajouter oups j'ai fait une erreur
6,5 qu'est-ce que j'ai fait là
j'ai fait une erreur
si c'est demi je crois
c'est ça si c'est demi et on repart sur
la fameuse berlinoise
maintenant de deux points c'est normal
je pense qu'il joue ce genre de
ce genre de set up je solide à partir
assez longue quand on mène au score
comme ça dans un match il reste beaucoup
de temps le timer qui a encore buggé ça
vient de cheesecom bien sûr sur timer
[Musique]
les pièces de se développer F4 avec G3
peut-être une idée intéressante
de s'activer
effectivement je donne des cours
c'est mon métier ça tu le sais toi tu le
sais
mais oui pour ceux qui auraient envie de
progresser aux échecs donne des cours
particuliers au groupe ce que vous
voulez
alors j'ai 4 a été joué par les blancs
ou cf5 ça a l'air ça a l'air assez
écrasant pour maintenir cette partie et
Kao qui fait un petit peu la gueule on a
l'impression que tout refaire suivi de
F5 F6 on pousse tous les pions ici et ça
a l'air très fort peut-être là mettre
une tour quelque part et venir pousser
je sais pas si j'ai le temps de faire ça
ça au pire ça je ne sais pas
pour me contacter alors j'ai un site
internet et tu as toutes les infos sur
mon site avec les contacts donc tu as
contacté ta
discord à mon mail mais le site je peux
vous le donner si vous voulez regarder
un petit peu
mon site et
tu peux avoir ta tous les trucs pour me
contacter toi ou un autre incisia si
jamais le chat vous avez envie de
progresser vous avez envie de me
contacter n'hésitez pas en tout cas je
stream aussi d'ailleurs pour ceux qui ne
savent pas le stream j'ai ma chaîne de
stream là ça fait un petit moment que
j'ai fait pause parce que j'ai vu
quelques soucis de santé premièrement et
je sens pas très bien là aujourd'hui ça
va vous avez de la chance mais c'est
vrai que dernièrement je ne suis pas
très très bien et c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait une petite pause
donc mais je stream aussi donc pour ceux
qui pour ceux qui voudraient me
rejoindre et bien sur ma chaîne twitch
et ben j'ai mon compte stouffe c'est
comme ça j'appelle sur twitch c'est
aussi une chaîne Youtube
chaîne Youtube qui active qui est et je
poste très régulièrement des vidéos donc
pareil pareil vous pouvez vous pouvez
aller voir ce que je fais sur Youtube
c'est tout échec c'est assez facile
si vous
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à venir me
voir sur les différents réseaux donc
twitch YouTube
cheesecom tout ce que vous voulez
et aussi d'ailleurs pour ceux qui nous
regardent actuellement là
actuellement sur sur Youtube et bien
penser aussi à vous abonner sur sur
Youtube vous savez que environ
70% des gens qui nous regardent sur
Youtube sont abonnés à la chaîne donc
abonnez-vous c'est gratuit et puis ça
vous permet d'être notifié à chaque fois
qu'il y a un événement à chaque fois
qu'il y a des vidéos qui sont postées
etc etc etc abonnez-vous un peu de
partout sur la chaîne de cheesecom sur
la chaîne stuff un peu de partout
comment ça se fait que tu arrives à
trouver la majorité des coûts
parce que oups
j'ai l'esprit un petit peu
mais on va dire après je pense à plein
de choses mais je joue pas tu vois j'ai
les idées quoi qui me viennent il y a
que la jauge c'est facile aussi tu sais
un petit peu ce qui se passe là je peux
manger les sous je peux manger là
ne t'inquiète pas que si je veux comme
Magnus
je serai pas là ce sera finalement avec
lui
donc je suis pas Magus
ok tout ici là je suis ravi de commencer
à pousser mais ça a l'air chaud
ça a l'air quand même pas mal ça va
arriver
là c'est c'est un coup
ça ça il veut te reprendre
il veut tout reprendre
et après ça arrive cavalier il voulait
ça et essayer de tenter la nul
il y a toujours là qu'elle a
pas mal je crois aussi
[Musique]
abandon et Magnus qui gagne deux parties
d'affilée après cette pause incroyable
Magnus qui revient presque au score il
va être encore moins un
donc il continue
[Musique]
je pense qu'il va ce qui va tomber c'est
possible que se laisse tomber
[Musique]
juste pour gagner un peu un petit peu de
temps la pendule bien évidemment il va
tout perdre
elle tour là il a poussé le pion à dames
il va faire le mat de
[Musique]
l'escalier
que tout le monde connaît ici
[Musique]
et la camera qui va se laisser tomber
voyez il reste 9 minutes 40 au timer
et Naka il lui reste 45 secondes il va
se laisser tomber passons la partie elle
est perdue mais il va faire exprès de de
perdre le maximum de temps parce que
vous savez que ça se joue à pas grand
chose donc là Magnus revient à un point
donc vous voyez hein donc après voilà
beaucoup de gens critiquent ce genre de
jeu moi j'aime pas perso là il va tomber
[Musique]
après classe mais on habitué bah ouais
d'ailleurs bon c'est
c'est parti du jeu
c'est parti du jeu c'est une règle qui
disait que c'est interdit il y aurait
pas ça après bon c'est parti du jeu
Magnus c'est pas s'il le ferait Magnus
ça est-ce qu'il le ferait je suis pas
sûr
je pense qu'il est pas sûr ok il a joué
allez prochaine partie ça a repris
et Magnus qui gagne une deuxième partie
d'affilée qui revient un point
qui revient
à un point de de ma carte donc le match
qui est très très serré là
je pense qu'il y a je pense qu'il y a il
y a des gens qui qui le feraient moi je
sais pas si je le ferai en fait moi je
pense moi j'ai toujours pas comme ça
vous savez que des fois avant les
tournois rapides ça se jouait en chaos
dans les clubs maintenant il y a
toujours d'un crans partout donc en fait
à l'époque tu pouvais flag en rapide
maintenant beaucoup moins parce qu'il y
a un incrément et
des fois tu avais des pièces de moins ou
des trucs comme ça et tu voulais enfin
tu refusais les nuls pour flag
l'adversaire un peu sale mais bon c'est
le jeu et en fait moi j'avais un petit
peu honte de Flag mon adversaire vous
savez que en vrai sur internet je flague
sans remords je n'ai rien à [__] ça
fait partie du jeu par contre sur un
vrai chéquier ben je trouve que ça fait
un peu honte de Flag comme un chien quoi
et du coup tu le fais un peu moins et du
coup je Flaguais si je sais que mon
adversaire me flagrait aussi
et donc je connaissais j'avais des amis
un club d'échec des joueurs qui
flaguaient à mort et je dis ok si je
compte lui et que ça cette situation je
le flag parce que je sais qu'il me le
ferait aussi par contre si je veux un
joueur que je respecte et que lui il
respecte bien le jeu la bande-annonce
vous voyez en fait ça dépend vraiment de
la personne qui je jouais et bon je suis
un vrai chéquier je trouve que c'est
plus dur
à faire ça vous imaginez Tina Kaye
le Flac c'est quand tu gagnes le temps
en fait gagner autant flag ça drapeau en
anglais et drapeau
qui tombe bref flag ça veut dire gagner
autant
et mais c'est parti du jeu clairement
mais IRL
je trouve que ça peut être un peu sale
des fois
et dans tous les cas dans tous les cas
tu as plus honte de le faire alors quand
tu es sur Internet
rien à faire on s'en fout quoi
mais juste imaginez juste tu as le même
tournoi IRL est-ce que quand il fasse 40
secondes la caméra il va se lever et
partir
je sais pas si de le faire
des comportements qui sont quand même je
pense purement online hors pacte les
mêmes choses
oui ben c'est parti du jeu c'est clair
c'est parti du jeu c'est clair mais des
fois il y a des plaques qui sont assez
pénibles par exemple quand un roi tour
en trois tours bah c'est nul quoi tu
vois juste et elle a joué pour gagner
autant c'est pas fair-play donc je
comprends que la part du jeu mais quand
c'est vraiment nul
en ta canta opposé et que c'est
complètement nul et que tu fais à 50
coups pour pour gagner autant
en fait quand vraiment la partie bon à
la fin du pilotant mais bon la partie
c'est jouer que c'était compliqué ok bon
voilà pour moi c'est la vie mais quand
c'est complètement nul et que tu refuses
la nuit juste pour gagner autant comme
ça j'aime pas ça j'aime pas pourtant je
suis un joueur qui flag mais ça dépend
vraiment comme toujours ça dépend je
pense
oui à l'époque il faudra pas
tu pouvais avoir 30 secondes comment
avoir 5 je sais pas toi
terrible maintenant tu peux plus je
pense tu vois les pendules avec
numérique et tout c'est quand même
différent quoi alors pour ces quatre
ici
donc position assez égale j'aime bien la
position noire je pense qu'il y a un peu
de travail avec un jour un B4 qui pour
arriver
à essayer de rendre des pions un petit
peu faibles mais bon je vois pas trop de
ta possibilité si je pense ça va faire
mieux c'est tranquille
ah oui il y a eu plein d'histoires
il y a une différence entre Flac pour
gagner de ce perdre autant
ah oui mais je suis d'accord
tu peux gagner en fait c'est parti du
jeu des fois à la fin il pourrait 5
secondes chacun et puis bah ça joue
voilà par contre juste
il y a des manières voilà je suis
d'accord avec toi et des manières des
fois juste c'est pas fair-play
et puis c'est comme ça
moi je me souviens une fois quand
j'étais quand j'étais plus jeune il y
avait j'avais joué un gars c'était pour
trois fois et les pions en face FGH FGH
et j'avais à la banlie une minute et
voilà l'adversaire il avait je sais pas
je pose une fois il me refuse
et en fait du coup moi j'appelle
l'arbitre à l'époque avec les chaos on
pouvait appeler l'arbitre pour venir bon
j'ai cette position je
sais que c'est nul donc je propose nul
mais il veut me flag donc du coup
l'arbitre a le droit de venir et il faut
regarder et c'est l'arbitre constate que
Lazare n'a pas fait de progrès dans la
position quand tu perds autant et ben il
peut donner la nul voilà et du coup du
coup je voulais partir et puis au bout
d'un moment adversaire il met la tour en
prise
je mange ça tourne et en fait c'était
fou c'est que c'était volontaire
il a fait exprès mon adversaire de la
tour en prise parce que
[Musique]
la route à la fin il a dit bah ok nul
enfin moi j'ai perdu autant j'ai mangé
la tour il m'a dit ok
[Musique]
j'ai essayé de gagner en sacrifiant
et en fait c'est vrai dans les lois
le livre de l'arbitre et Ben et ben tu
vois vraiment que le mec a essayé de
gagner même si il a fait exprès par la
tour mais l'arabique il a dit que
c'était tellement mesquin etc il a dit
bah non je mets nul mais en vrai
il y a vraiment des escrocs comme un peu
dans tous les
dans tous les milieux des gens qui sont
malhonnêtes comme ça
pour cette partie qui va faire nulle qui
vont s'échanger moi je vais faire ça à
ça pendant que tu vas faire ça
vraiment les pions sont pas prenables on
voit qu'il va qui va monter comme faire
attention avec les Noirs parce que je
peux arriver avec mon roi ici à un
moment donné
mais bon normalement il y a pas trop de
problèmes quand je mangerai la Tour
Eiffel et c'est nul ça va être signé
c'est signé donc personne qui a toujours
son point de retard
on va le rajouter leur point
ajouter leur petit point ici 9 8
hop et si les deux joueurs sont à zéro
et Ben et ben c'est match nul de toute
façon
ça a changé maintenant mais à l'époque
c'était match nul
ok donc cette position on l'a déjà eu
plein de fois où les 5 fois qu'on l'a
pas eu encore aujourd'hui on va les
joueurs qui changent pas mal leur schéma
la partie finale combien de points
en fait c'est le temps réglementaire il
reste 35 secondes en 3 + 1 c'est écrit
en haut à gauche le timer qui descend
quand ça arrive à zéro et ben le 7 se
termine donc là c'est la dernière partie
du 7
et ensuite on aura une demi-heure de une
plus une Bullet et à l'issue des bullets
et ben sera terminé donc il y a pas
vraiment de si tu veux de
points de match hein que tu vas gagner
c'est plus toujours contre la
Bullet c'est la cadence très rapide
comme là tu vois il y a marqué 1 + 1
pour la troisième pour le troisième set
c'est une minute plus une seconde
parcours donc ça va très très vite
ça va très vite et là c'est vraiment les
réflexes et tout et Nakamura
c'est aussi un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde
le meilleur donc Magnus et Naka c'est
peut-être même les deux meilleurs
joueurs du LED il y a aussi affirme déjà
très très bon jean de Bullet d'ailleurs
avait battu Magnus lors du championnat
du monde de Bullet qui avait eu lieu
qui a environ 25 50 en élo quoi ce qui
est pas mal
mais bon 2550
Fides
bon la nuit
il arrive quand même à faire la
différence
et c'est vrai qu'il est très rapide
pingouin mais si tu arrives à
jouer d'échec un petit peu tu le
défonces quoi c'est pareil aussi un
arrowninsky même profil que pingouin en
plus fort même profil
mais bon je pense que les nacres
en tout cas c'est c'est ce que je pense
c'est mon
et mon ressenti
alors cette baguette ambulette alors
pour qu'il égalise il faut gagner cette
partie le score c'est 9 8 en faveur de
Nakamura c'est la dernière partie de
blitztimer qui est arrivé à 0
donc ça gagne cool que Magnus égalise
avant le Bullet ce serait magique ce
serait magnifique
après tout se passer même si il passe
cette partie Magnus il peut très bien
gagné ambulette et se refaire ça il y a
pas de souci là-dessus et c'est vrai que
vu le niveau de Naka aussi ambulette m'a
commencé avec égalité c'est quand même
quand même pas mal
cache 5 qui a été le dame B6 je pense
qu'on a quand même envie de garder les
dames
[Musique]
c'est pas un truc je peux manger mais
juste voilà
on sent qu'il y a une pression G6 et
c'est encore comme G5 dans les cases
blanches donc on a envie quand même en
gestion qui a été à jouer j'aime bien le
coup cavalier
j'ai 4 pour venir taper un peu les cases
là-haut et même pourquoi pas un jour
qu'elle va H2 cavalier G4 ni en E3 et
venir en F5 c'est très très long je
pourrais aussi venir ici pour venir F5
c'était plus rapide d'ailleurs
pourquoi je me casse les pieds à faire
36 coups de cavaliers bon au moins il y
avait pas de prendre des quatre mais
c'est vrai que quand une grosse
concession bien par des Noirs parce que
quasiment retour du roi serait un salon
ouverte cavalier C8 pour défendre le
pion et cavaler B7 et je trouve que
c'est une position difficile pour pour
les pièces un peu mal placées grosse
faiblesse aussi en D6 imaginez le tour
des trois tours D1 pour continuer à ta
pression ici mais T5 aussi qui peut
arriver
la destin qui leur cavalise B6 ah non
les gars n'importe quoi dis n'importe
quoi
peut-être qu'avec 5
c'est chaud
et aussi cavalier à 4
c'est pas possible c'est un coup
libérateur essayer de faire un truc
comme ça à un moment donné ça reste de
craquer un si tu joues pas des 5 ça a
été joué des cinq on continue à ta
question alors ce pion qui risque d'être
perdu un jour il y a eu des quatre ou B4
waouh
c'est marrant comment il s'en fout
complètement du pion des 4 mai parce
qu'il sait qu'il y a un vis-à-vis
est-ce que il a pas envie de jouer ici
cavaler ces deux
et
aller manger des quatre pendant que lui
bouge plus à cause du vis-à-vis ce
serait malin quand même
F5 cavalier prend dans un pion
toujours pareil il pourra pas manger
essayer de toujours ça en l'air est-ce
que fouet 2 c'est une idée
je pensais ici
et je prends des cadres c'est de manger
ce pion avec une pièce ça peut être cool
c'est le problème en fait
il a joué
ah tu parlais de ces deux
[Musique]
ça marchait pas ça marchait pas mais je
le demande maintenant j'avais tout
ranger 7
on reprend GSM ou échec et
j'arrivais à temps j'arrive à attendre
une cape bon c'était mais je l'ai pas vu
de base donc
mais il y avait je crois que ça marchait
pas on pourrait vérifier après si tu
veux après c'est la pause
on vérifiera après mais je crois que ça
marchait pas
et là du coup l'options qui sont très
fort ici tourne la tour là tour là voilà
tour ici
Magnus qui peut faire mal dans cette
partie j'ai pas fait peut-être
malheureusement je suis cloué
pour B6 c'est un coup étroit
et faire tourner là-haut voilà alors pas
mal non
et chaque
est tour ici est-ce qu'on peut essayer
d'aller manger une pion des quatre et
pas évident échec tour ici
je suis pas sûr qu'on va réussir
il y a un pion de plus pour pour les
blancs
mais ce pion qui avance maintenant c'est
très compliqué des deux rois rouges
moi il va perdre le plan des deux il
prend
mais la vitesse à laquelle il joue hein
les joueurs c'est impressionnant quand
même
passionnant ils sont très complexes je
vois tempo
comment est-ce qu'on gagne ça avec les
Blancs pas évident six secondes à la
pendule
je découpe pour gagner un petit peu de
temps
et en plus
maintenant
son tour
[Musique]
ça va faire mieux peut-être
ça joue encore la refuser la nul Magnus
ça va trop vite les gars
ça va trop vite pour moi
monter le Bullet avec 5 secondes chacun
c'est totalement impossible
cette finale qui a l'air quand même pas
mal ce pion passé il y a un pion de plus
simple tout aussi écoutez ça va gagner
pour les blancs le roi qui va venir en
F6
ici on pousse le pion c'est gagné ma gus
qui fait rapporter cette partie
incroyable courage 7 et F7 ça va gagner
même manger ici c'est complètement
gagnant pour Magnus
7 F7 abondant
voilà donc quand on prend merci au
revoir écoutez 9 9 dans ce match Magnus
qui est qui a réussi à bien revenir et
t'aimer le 3 points avant la reprise du
deuxième set donc magnifique Magnus un
qui arrive à 9,9 avant le Bullet malus
qui a réussi à gagner trois parties
d'affilée c'est c'est assez assez énorme
alors rapidement je voulais vous montrer
ah oui ils étaient ce chat alors je sais
plus qui m'empêche
qui m'a dit qu'il y avait peut-être une
tactique c'est très bien vu de ta part
mais je crois que ça marche pas revenir
un tout petit peu après tu me disais
qu'il y avait peut-être
[Musique]
qui est peut-être
ici
moi j'ai tout reprend tout reprend tout
reprend et c'est de effectivement je
pars venir ici
mais ici j'ai tout reprend G7 et si on
reprend j'ai échec B2
ce que je disais ici et ici si je
faisais ça
sur ça
ah j'ai chaque là voilà en fait moi je
veux pas manger parce que sinon tu fais
chèque et tu viens défendre le pion et
ma tour elle pourra pas empêcher de plus
avancer et j'ai pas ça à cause de plus
on prend mais si tu fais roi fuite j'ai
fou échec tu prends en transpose par
cette ligne elle empêche le fou
d'avancer et tu fais roi ici j'ai échec
et je
te fais
ça gagne ça
[Musique]
quelque part
ça et ça c'est chaud
c'est chaud en tout cas
[Musique]
bouge pas mon roi il y a pas d'échec et
il y a trop de jeux sur ton en fait
vraiment c'est juste perdu
sors ça il dit ça
en fait
pour des vitres
[Musique]
F7
tours de l'ordinateur
échec échec et maths
mais bon ok tout ça pour dire 24 que tu
as voilà non en vrai les joueurs ils
l'ont vu par exemple
les joueurs si tu veux ils ont vu que ça
marche pas
ils ont vu ça
ils ont vu ça et ce sont dit ok stop ça
marche pas et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
pas joué ça mais c'est clair que ce coup
là ça
va marcher quand tu le vois
donc en tout cas Magnus qui est revenu
au score je suis très content et des
blettes qui vont commencer ici une
minute alors je vais faire un truc je
vais rester en stream je vais juste
mettre une pause de environ une minute
trente un truc à faire à côté
et c'est pas notre toilettes c'est un
truc généralement un truc à faire je
reviens dans une minute pour pour le
Bullet donc on a une demi-heure boulette
et j'arrive ah oui les points alors
et après je vais aller faire mon truc
donc là c'est Naka qui a gagné
et voilà on fera une prédit aussi juste
après pour le Bullet j'arrive dans une
minute
[Musique]
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présence ciel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis revenu 9 9 dans ce match le
joueur qui vont bientôt sur Installer
pour le Bullet donc on a une demi-heure
de partie à une plus une donc là ça va
vraiment être la vérité donc si
il y a un égalité il y aura un tie-break
consiste en quatre parties
de Bullet
pour après faire un Armageddon
très très chaud
on va faire d'ailleurs sous la
prédiction pendant que les joueurs
s'installe on fait la même prédiction
pour le Bullet
5 minutes
pour
là bien sûr je parle que de sections
de
que les 7 donc là pour l'instant je vous
laisse parier sur votre favori
[Musique]
après là c'est un plus un donc c'est un
Bullet un peu différente d'habitude
parce que c'est quand même une seconde
parcours donc c'est pas le gros Bullet
trashedon c'est quoi c'est une partie
décisive ou en fait les Noirs auront
toujours plus de temps que l'adversaire
mais peuvent faire mieux non c'est
l'inverse et non au moins de temps par
exemple armage dedans général c'est 5
minutes pour les blancs et 4 minutes
pour les Noirs donc une huile d'avance
pour ce qu'elle est blanc mais en cas de
nul c'est noir gagne voilà ce qu'on
Armageddon si jamais les joueurs sont
égalité
vous allez voir le format des départages
4 minutes de 1 + 1 couleur alternée et
en cas d'égalité armage et donc une
partie une partie qui va rester là dans
la partie chaise donc vous avez le le la
possibilité de pouvoir parier sur votre
favori ambulette donc
vous avez les enchères avec qui sont
partis avec 70 cas sur Magnus
et une plus grosse croûte encore sur la
nul franchement les gars si vous voulez
prendre des points je vous invite à
parier sur la nul ou sur ma carte parce
que
parce que bon enfin c'est pas vrai
mais par rapport au point en jeu c'est
un peu la folie quoi
en tout cas c'est c'est vraiment deux de
meilleurs joueurs du monde je pense
qu'avec avec sirop on a vraiment le 3
meilleurs joueurs du monde en Bullet
donc là ils vont s'affronter pour le
gain du speech 2023
et deux joueurs qui sont vraiment
intraitables dans cette dans ces cas-là
9 9 en tout cas c'est cool que Magnus a
réussi à revenir au score il était mené
de trois points dans ce deuxième set
et maintenant il a réussi à égaliser
avant le début des bullets une
demi-heure de une plus une
et ça va être ça va partir dans un
instant j'attends que la partie se lance
je pense dans quelques secondes on va
aller voir comment c'est
une plus c'est du Bullet mais il y a
quand même une seconde d'incrément donc
c'est pas évident je pense que c'est un
peu comme si ouais
un peu comme si on avait du 2 minutes je
pense à peu près deux chaos
et on voit les joueurs comment je le
vois genre
3351 et Magnus qui a 336
c'est juste de complètement abuser
3300 les gars allez ça part là-dessus et
on a la caméra qui a des blancs dans
cette première partie d'ailleurs cette
ouverture on l'a déjà vu hier dans le
match
c'est pas hier tu as avant-hier dans le
match de Maxime contre contre Naka et
ben on l'a vu cette cette position
dame G3 attention il faut prendre un H6
cavalier H4 le fou
qui revient et Naka qui qui joue vite en
tout cas un aka qui va essayer de jouer
vite mais ta pression au temps
la pression sur
deux et aussi pour jouer le tour en 1
etc c'est pas mal les pièces s'échangent
[Musique]
on garde les pièces chez Magnus
je sais pas ce que tu as parié en tout
cas route mais j'ai payé j'ai tout payé
j'ai tout payé
donc je sais pas
dans B5
attention il faut défendre là comment on
joue là
ça a l'air chiant
[Musique]
B2
ok mais quand même je mange aussi non
du mal à comprendre vraiment
[Musique]
ce qui se passe
il prend un 4 en B2
ça va venir route ok nickel
[Musique]
F2 sachant que tout redonner plus
possible moi je vois bien un truc comme
ça et là
kaki qui est mal au temps il est pas
content d'accord il est pas content du
tout d'apprendre des quatre a été joué
dans B2 F3 il a pris à deux
[Musique]
c'est quoi là
la souris
est-ce que vous voulez pour cette pour
ce match est-ce que vous voulez les gars
changer de scène
est-ce que ça vous dit de passer sur
cette scène là dites-moi vite rapidement
est-ce que vous préférez ça ou pas on me
voit plus mais
[Musique]
mais vous voyez les joueurs un peu plus
grand
[Musique]
ouais vous préférez allez on fait on
laisse celle-là
[Musique]
je pense pour le Bullet c'est cool comme
ça au moins vous voyez plus
vous voyez plus les les réactions des
joueurs etc faites pas mal
[Musique]
ben ça
fait partie du jeu hein encore une fois
l'échec sur Internet spécial c'est
particulier et ben ouais le flag est
autorisé le mixclic et autorisé mais
c'est vrai quand même que quand on voit
un peu de l'extérieur bah ça fait quand
même deux mises clics de Magnus dans ce
match et ils perd 19 en ce match qui
pourrait quand même
en vouloir de ces mises clics c'est pas
il y avait un pire tout à l'heure il y a
eu un pire bien pire que celui là
cavalier 3
ok tour bien tours on va venir en P4
cavalier il y a plein de problèmes un
peu de partout
j'aime bien ce qui fait ma cycle la
casse C5 qui va être emprunté par une
pièce c'est pas laquelle
tour ici attention la fourchette quand
même qui peut arriver à cahier de est-ce
qu'on peut jouer les 6 rois ici il y
aura Tortank on reprend et cavaler B2 à
la fin
pas simple de tout ce que fait ici Naka
ça va être la même hein
j'aime pas tout ce que fait ce que fait
ici à Magnus
je pense là il va la perdre
c'est pas la perdre je pense même j'ai
trois il y a cavalier prend H3
bouger il avait super casque cavalier
Magnus qui va encore faire cette partie
c'est dur
de mettre en haut à droite mais
la scène pas faite pour ça
route donc on va laisser comme ça c'est
pas grave
c'est dur mais attention c'est dur mais
c'est pas fini il faut prendre ces cinq
attention à ces deux qui est une menace
est-ce que je peux réussir à défendre ou
ici tourbouge c'est très passif mais
c'est bon
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut
OK
à 3
comment je passe tous les deux sur deux
j'ai roi B2 le cavalier est en prise
parce que va réussir à tenir ça serait
quand même la bonne nouvelle
créer des cartes qui va arriver
peut-être elle joue comme ça
cette partie je vous garantis que Magnus
enfin que il va la jouer
cette position n'a qu'à
parce que il joue beaucoup le temps
il mène dans le coin il veut qu'il y ait
le moins de parties possibles donc il va
celle là le 50 coups
donc 50 coups sans prise ni mouvement
pion
donc on va la jouer celle-là on va aller
celle-là beaucoup de temps
enfin
ça va faire 50
un moment donné la règle c'est 50 coups
sont prises ni mouvement de pions donc
Magnus jouera aucun pion
priori Naka en jouera pas après la cape
toujours faire F5 un jour pour
pour débloquer le compteur vous savez
regarder 5 du coup on est reparti pour
50 coups
on est reparti pour 50 coups par ce que
Ben 50 ans prise ni mouvement de pions
et quand il arrivera à une quarantaine
de coups bah il fera le 4 après il va
manger après il fera j'ai 4 et voilà
[Musique]
c'est c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça
bah c'est pas Jacques moderne c'est
chèque sur Internet
c'est parti du jeu j'ai envie de dire
c'est moche je suis bien d'accord avec
vous
mais c'est comme ça
c'est le genre après il y en a qui le
font d'autres qui se font pas
et c'est vrai que
que Naka fait partie des gens qui le
font
cavalier ici pas beaucoup de cases donc
il a mangé un pion
par contre c'était le bad bits
et maintenant ça va continuer à jouer
alors je sais pas si
est-ce que ça peut tenir cette finale je
pense que oui
et
il fait beaucoup aussi
soit il le fait maintenant
après les joueurs comme Maxime
Magnus normalement ça fait quand même
beaucoup moins
joueur qui respecte un peu plus
H35 coups
ça va faire nul allez on prend la on
prend la et c'est adios
par contre là il faut vraiment
allez faut prendre maintenant
il va attendre tellement pour le faire
gagne du temps à la pendule qui
mériterait de perdre autant et qui a un
petit lag une petite seconde et perdre
temps il mériterait
[Musique]
il mériterait
vous avez la synthétie on va rajouter le
score
pour les joueurs 17
[Musique]
on a fait la prédiction non ça c'est un
je crois que oui
je crois qu'on l'a fait
alors
encore les mêmes positions
[Musique]
des deux probablement damlage 5 ou dame
G4 on évite la dame sur le roi ambulette
l'attaque c'est vraiment important
l'initiative ta pression sur la position
mais aussi
au temps c'est de vous voyez il met le
fou en direction du roi
ces quatre a été joué ça empêche de 5
aussi
vous voyez que
à gauche et ben il y a des blancs il y a
la pendule blanche qui tourne s'afficher
certes deux fois dans la caméra
[Musique]
commence
en bas avec les Blancs vous avez
carreaux
avec les Blancs
qui va gagner un petit pion avec tourbe
B2
ah oui vous avez le temps regarder vous
avez le temps à gauche en blanc et le
temps à droite en noir ben juste à
gauche c'est blanc et à droite c'est
noir c'est comme ça
[Musique]
qui pousse ses pions ce petit pion
d'avance
être perdu un jour comment est-ce que
j'arrive à pousser un F4 intéressant
et ici faudrait que j'arrive à ramener
la tour ou le fou quelque part pour
aller virer ces pièces
[Musique]
F4 est joué je pense que le roi qui va
venir en D5 c'est d'aller manger ce pion
ce purge à 5
et là c'est la grosse erreur de des
carreaux qui donnent le pion
et là les pions par des fous sont de
couleur enfin de même couleur
et du coup ça favorise pas la nul au
contraire
on croit ici le pion risque d'être perdu
un jour 4 peut être un très bon coup
ça a été joué c'était pas le bon coup
apparemment
pourtant ça avait l'air pas mal quand
même
l'option est perdu ici mais je prends
des 4
et une fois que je prends mes quatre
quand même et ben j'ai accès qu'à pas
mal de choses
il va donner j'ai 5 qui prend tout ici
et je pense voilà on pousse le pion ici
ça va ça peut être gagnant je pense
direct
que roi des deux c'est un coup d’abord
aille en celui-là échec et il pousse
tous les pions F3 qui va arriver
sûrement la CF2
ou ici et F2 doit gagner direct
maintenant c'est pas ce qu'il a encore
[Musique]
bloque en plus les pions les pions
blancs
prise
il a fait H6 comment on gagne ça ou ces
trois peut-être
et on passe le roi par là
un truc comme ça pour faire F2
ça peut gagner ça je pense Magnus qui va
gagner les gars
de gagner plus facilement ou prend voilà
et ça va dame de manière imparable
mais attention la finale elle est
complexe si je fais ça
ça gagne direct Magnus en finale on lui
fait pas ça dame imparable il y avait
des quatre nuls dans cette finale avec
le fou de la mauvaise couleur etc bref
pas trop vite en Bullet j'ai du mal à
tous vous expliquer mais
en gros c'est très très
au niveau
très très haut niveau son match
donc il reste encore 15 minutes de match
et le score il est égal
tu préférais la scène d'avant gebe games
oui après moi ça m'est égal si vous
voulez regarder si vous voulez je peux
vous faire une un sondage
voilà
si vous voulez dites-moi ce que vous
préférez la vue la viande grande ou la
vue petite avec toutes les caméras dont
la mienne je vous laisse voter et après
on fera ce que vous voulez moi ça m'est
égal
mais ces classes c'est quand même c'est
quand même sympa à suivre
je pense qu'on trouvera des jours en
grand on va aller à la belle chambre de
Magnus et la belle chemise de la gare en
grand ce qui a un pire sympa
Magnus il y a pas mal de choses qui vont
arriver il y a tortues
ce qui peut arriver aussi c'est chaud en
cahier des quatre et c'est du cavalier
F3
je n'y comprends rien je comprends puis
on prend tour G7 c'est chaud c'est le
bordel
c'est le bordel complet il y a ça en
prise possible
pour G3 a été joué
[Musique]
ta F5 là j'ai Torcé 7 aussi qui est
possible j'ai cette petite possible je
pense c'est gagnant pour les blancs mais
parce que le roi il est faible et j'ai
le pion type avancé mais bon il est
quand même pas mal contre le jeu
notamment sur F2 et c'est très très
compliqué tout achète les jouets là il y
a pas de touristique qui gagne
directrice
là je me la set dame là-haut
comment je finis
je crois qu'il a une belle tactique
Magnus
après il y a plein d'avance
ça va gagner un juste tranquillement et
Magnus qui va commencer à prendre
l'avantage dans ce dans cette dernière
section de Bullet d'un point et F7 a
gagné des règles aussi
tous les trois ça gagne aussi et Magnus
qui gagne cette partie
on va être en grand du coup à les gars
39 à 10 on va rester un grand
et je vais être le score
11,5
plus un pour Magnus dans ce match il
reste 15 minutes
maintenant et peut-être que tout à
l'heure la nulle qu'il a faite je sais
pas combien de coups ça va lui porter
près de 10 maintenant parce qu'il a
ralenti le jeu et maintenant il est mené
vous voyez alors que si
tu as plus de temps plus de chance de
revenir au score en tout cas
mais il veut gagner ce match il est
important ça je voulais dire pour les
deux joueurs les joueurs ils ont
vraiment envie de gagner la casse c'est
un grand streamer peut-être le plus
grand streamer d'échec et et Magnus il a
aussi il avait donné son son envie de de
gagner ce match il veut montrer que
c'est le patron les deux joueurs veulent
montrer qu'ils sont sont les meilleurs
joueurs tout simplement
sans le laisser un spa une surprise mais
ils veulent montrer qu'ils sont le
meilleur tout simplement
pour ces deux
pour virer la tour d'ici et après manger
B2
pas simple comme décision à prendre il a
pris des cinq qui va abandonner du coup
le pion B2 et le pion à deux
donc faut prendre puis on prend et
surtout prends à deux je prends je
prends à 4
peut-être que du coup ça peut
[Musique]
assez cher un peu la position peut-être
manger ici manger à deux ok ma préfère
tout simplement rendre le matos car elle
est des deux
cette finale qui est assez égale et
maintenant vous voyez c'est manuscrit
noir et Magnus qui devrait maintenant
essayer de de faire durer la partie
parce qu'il mène dans le score et
franchement ça serait bien fait on a
qu'à mais Magnus n'est pas comme ça
Magnus joue la position je pense si la
position elle est égale je pense qu'il
va il va juste jouer à la poste tout
simplement
enfin je crois pas qu'il va jouer la
position vous voyez là il a répété
Magnus
c'est pas un joueur qui joue il joue
time comme Naka le fait
régulièrement
[Musique]
elle est quand même complètement nulle
même Magnus en fait je sais pas oui je
pense que
qui peut temporiser aussi
mais bon
[Musique]
ok bouge le roi on
et qui joue quand même très très vite
un cas à une vitesse c'est à fond
F5 ça va changer
[Musique]
les chances
mais bon en vrai il y a pas beaucoup de
chance qui bouge il y a ça ça
va répéter
oui Magnus répète en vrai il pourrait
essayer de
il pourrait essayer de pas répéter
Magnus pour gagner du temps à l'envers
ça sûrement
refuser la répète
c'est
12 11 pour Magnus
dans ce match très très chaud il reste 9
minutes
seulement 9 minutes dans ce match et
quartz qui gagne 12 11
prise elle prend H3
c'est 4 mais tout cavalier en C3 D5
même
là ça part sur du
G4 G5
d'un cas qui qui joue qui joue vraiment
des pollutions très agressives
j'aime bien la j'aime bien la pose de la
cave en vrai qui avait H4 ça a l'air ça
a l'air intéressant
j'aime beaucoup la pollution de ma
caméra ici
même si c'est chaud en fait car scène il
a gagné tous les dames tout ce
territoire il est à Magnus mais de
l'autre côté ça va ça risque de chauffer
un peu sur le roi sur le roi blanc avec
les pièces qui arrivent comme ça qui
peut aussi arriver et pas évident mais
si Manu ça arrive à attaquer en premier
oui par là par exemple ça peut être ça
peut être chaud
donc défend bien on peut imaginer un
jour un petit ours 3 qui peut en venir
un peu défendre
à mes souhaits
alors d'être un coup
intéressant j'aime bien aussi roi F1 un
jour j'aime bien ouais pour m'enlever du
vis-à-vis et essayer de voyez de
temporiser un peu avec mon roi là
prise prise
mais la Torse tête c'est un peu peur de
toi c'est un peu compliqué
merci merci
merci ciel bleu
alors surprise d'en prendre
les blancs sont pas mal au final même
tour de huit
ça enlève des pièces au noir pour
pouvoir attaquer quand tu vois la police
ça fait peur il y a aussi fou ça qui
fait peur quand même
ça menace pas mal de choses et là il se
passe quoi ça c'est impossible il y
avait la tour en prise
qui a été un mauvais coup pourquoi
pourquoi
on prend un seul cavalier chaque raté
par Magnus
j'ai mis l'ordi dans ces moments-là on
voyait que moi je suis pas moi je vois
rien
[Musique]
je vais enlever ça
allez 5 secondes pour ma caméra contre
15 dans une position hyper compliquée un
tour prend S7 c'est peut-être dame échec
d'un projet d'eux c'est extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué mais ça a l'air
quand même de bien tourner peut-être
pour pour Magnus qui a une pièce de plus
maintenant prise et ça va être abandon
je pense très bientôt pour
d'un échec Tour Eiffel bien joué et ici
carreau qui devrait abandonner pour
passer à l'autre partie il abandonne et
Marius qui s'envole dans ce match et que
maintenant plus de
plus de pour Magnus
je change de score
avec 13 11 pour Magnus il reste 5
minutes donc là pour vous dire les
choses clairement Nakamura doit
absolument gagner la prochaine partie et
sûrement encore la prochaine ça c'est
quasiment obligatoire vous savez que
Naka il fait moins de mimiques je vais
voir si je peux vous tourner un peu la
caméra et essayer de vous mettre entrer
un peu plus Naka qui est un petit peu
sur le côté je pense que oui
vous le verrez un peu mieux comme ça
voilà on voit mieux
[Musique]
on est bien ici
et en tout cas
Nakamura qui est obligé de gagner c'est
Magnus gagne celle-là terminé parce
qu'une partie de une plus une ça dure
environ 4 minutes vous voyez donc si
personne là il y aura trois parties
rattraper avec plus beaucoup de temps
sera impossible par contre il y a
quelqu'un de celle là il aura le temps
de jouer encore une autre partie et de
éventuellement de
de
sauver la balle de Max
[Musique]
donc là c'est chaud avec Naka qui envoie
tout
il envoie tout
qui a été joué
et bon c'est chaud
qui va tomber
Magnus qui est qui a pas peur en voilà
j'ose ce qui est monté vraiment tout en
haut il y a des menaces de maths un peu
de partout il y a du cavalier prend ici
qui peut arriver aussi
dommage
là le roi qui va partir en recette ça a
l'air totalement perdu pour pour Magnus
avec son roi complètement à poil H7
c'est un coup
ça va être un B7 avec tout reprendre je
crois qu'il va perdre
commence
comment ça gagne cavalier F5 a été fait
pour manger la dame sur échec sur un
point et si je prends ici et fais dame
imparable Maggie qui perd cette partie
rigole et ils savent que Magnus voyait
et ben il joue un petit peu le rôle que
fait Naka il attend un peu au final et
en fait cette bonne guerre contre la
quelle tu le fais franchement il est
tellement de fois que cette bonne guerre
et on commence sûrement la dernière
partie du match enfin sûrement peut-être
pas si Nakamura a gagné que les noirs et
ben on aura droit à un départage continu
ne gagne pas avec les noirs et ben on
aura probablement un amuse carcène
champion du speeds 2023
il reste encore 2 minutes 20 dans ce
match mais une partie de une plus une
dure environ 3-4 minutes normalement
donc je pense que c'est la dernière
partie après je me trompe peut-être je
pense que c'est là dans la partie donc
tout le monde veut le taille break alors
je sais pas ce que vous avez parié par
rapport au 7 de 1 + 1 mais en tout cas
pour l'instant
ceux qui ont parlé sur maca et ben vous
avez je pense perdu
et je sais pas ce que vous avez parlé
des autres peut-être des nuls peut-être
des
gains de Magnus en tout cas on est je
pense bien sur la peut-être dernière
partie avec ma news qui fait une belle
position ici
c'est pas mal
[Musique]
ou à deux ou attention attention
dame C3
moi ce qu'on joue ici dans mes chèques
ça sert à rien il y aura des deux de
repartir 3 B2 ça reste chaud encore hein
H5
c'est quoi les deux il veut manger H6 ok
assez chaud en tout cas 38 secondes
chacun
un pion plus pour Naka avec obligation
de gagner pour G5 attention la dame qui
a été joué
[Musique]
3b7 peut-être avec tour à 8 et A4
qui va arriver
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup la position de Naka je
pense qu'on va sûrement arriver un
tie-break
c'est ce qu'on risque d'avoir
probablement
la récupérer son petit pion Magnus mais
là il y a trop de regarder dame dans mes
fins
[Musique]
si tu prends là il faut regarder ce qui
se passe et chaque roi là est-ce que
vraiment je gagne ça a l'air quand même
il a mangé
et encore un blender enfin les gars les
gars
je sais pas si vous voyez la jauge qui
fait que de monter de descendre à chaque
coup
il s'est passé beaucoup de choses et on
va Magnus qui a l'air content
les gars n'arrêté pas mal de choses et
je crois que ça va perdre il y a des
échecs de partout avec le fou on va
regarder à la liste des gars parce que
là on nous voit absolument rien en tout
cas Magnus qui a fait match nul la même
pas essayé de mater il savait qu'avec la
nul il gagnait le match alors rapidement
on va essayer de comprendre je vais vous
mettre la scène
je crois que j'ai pas de scène sans les
joueurs donc on va quand même garder
celle-là plus rapidement voir ce qui
s'est passé donc Magnus qui est champion
du speechez avec très ennemis à 12 et
demi face à la caméra chaque fois qu'il
se joue ça joue au point près donc
franchement c'était c'était très très
compliqué alors pourquoi ça fait nul
comment ça fait nul rapidement ben c'est
de comprendre alors je vais avancer un
petit peu à la position où la jauge elle
a commencé à devenir complètement folle
il y a eu ces prises en Russie c'est
apparemment le grand coup c'était Damart
roi C2
voilà dame bien voilà
d'apprendre des 6
[Musique]
et bon bah c'est fini voilà je menace
plein de choses ça a l'air terminé pour
pour les blancs au lieu de ça
il a fait tout un avec l'idée qu'il
pensait menacer maths
sauf que là et ben les deux joueurs ont
raté
et seront après d'un point échec et
apparemment c'est maintenant 10 il y a
plein d'échecs de partout il y a au pire
il y a des plantes et là du coup n'a
qu'à
aller sur de au moins fermer enfin
perdre nulle part du coup par le match
et surtout un
dame C2 qui est très mal joué ça perd
encore
le gain est très joli regardez un joli
les gars c'est nous ici
et sur quoi prend parfait celle-là
je passe par là c'est magnifique
magnifique comment les ex ça peut être
des fois géométriques
et du coup il a rajouté très vite et là
cette fois-ci il s'est pris ton dessert
alors tout reprend B6 avec un prof de 5
ça a gagné aussi comme tout à l'heure et
surtout là voilà
tour princesse
qui donne toutes ses pièces pour arriver
pour arriver à faire plein de
papituelles apparemment la position
allait maths c'est gagnant pour
pour les blancs avec Full 5 il y a une
proposition de nul qui est acceptée et
abandon de façon c'est maths sur wallah
et sur roi ici des quatre voilà comment
c'est mat dans mes chèques voilà Dame
des 7 sur voilà j'ai mate comme ça et
sur oasis SEMAT comme ça votre façon en
tournant et tu auras vu le match ici
comme hymen d'un point et qui sait que
ça va dans la partie et ben après chaque
voilà il aurait fait échec on aurait vu
une perpétuelle comme ça donc en tout
cas en tout cas hyper beau match entre
les deux les deux meilleurs joueurs du
monde dans ce format là entre 45 et
Nakamura et quarantaine du coup qui
finit par gagner ce match de seulement
un point donc supérieurement en tout cas
à suivre
sur tescom rapidement avant de partir
juste vous rappeler pour ceux qui qui
sont sur Youtube et qui nous regardent
n'hésitez pas à
fond la chaîne avant de partir quand
même dommage de de ne pas follow lors
que vous avez vu tout événement avec
nous et pour ceux qui sont aussi sur sur
twitch et qui n'ont pas encore follow la
chaîne bien évidemment c'est pareil
n'hésitez pas à follow la chaîne c'est
gratuit et vous serez toujours au
courant et dès que il y a des événements
qui qui se jouent
[Musique]
et puis après je vous dirai bonne soirée
à tous donc ça fait quoi en bulletin
et hop voilà pour l'après midi donc je
vous dis bonne soirée à tous et puis
merci encore c'était un super plaisir de
suivre l'abonnement avec vous je vous
dis à très bientôt Ciao